Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Da ist er.
Gehts mit dem Mikrofon?
Ja, das weiss man bei Windows immer nicht so genau.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, wo war das jetzt?
Das ist ja mittlerweile alles super versteckt.
Input Volume 80, ja ich glaube das hatten wir sonst auch immer.
E-Z
Hör mal, was jetzt?
Vor GTA
GTA 6 gab es wieder irgendwelche Leaks, habe ich gesehen.
Wobei ich sagen muss, GTA, glaube ich der einzige in der Gaming-Welt, GTA geht voll an mir vorbei.
Ich habe, also ganz ehrlich, ich glaube ich habe nie einen GTA-Teil, egal welchen, 1 bis 5.
Ich habe nie einen durchgespielt im Singleplayer.
Und GTA Multiplayer oder Roleplay Gedöns geht mir auch mal voller Marsch vorbei.
Interessiert mich überhaupt gar nicht. So wir müssen gerade mal kurz die VM updaten. Die haben
wir bestimmt schon ewig nicht mal geupdatet. Aus London. Pock was machst du in London? Ah ne,
es war nicht Cubecon irgendwo letztens? Aber es war in München oder? Nicht in London. Oder ist
auch die laut
wir machen mal kurz vor einem update sonst vergesse ich das wieder was auf
der cube dann ist die cube con doch in london war die nicht in münchen oder
Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Irgendwelches Cloud und Zeug war auch in München letztens.
Ach, so immer.
Ich verfolge das auch nur am Rande, solange ich da nicht selbst hingehe.
Wenn ich selbst hingehe, bin ich etwas informierter.
Aber was juckt es mich, ne?
Wenn ich da hingehe.
So, guck mal.
Wir sind so früh.
Ne, wollte ich gerade sagen.
Der Keks ist nicht Bad Girl.
Hier.
Nicht der Keks.
Pepo ist am Essen.
Das ist gut.
Ja, gegessen habe ich schon.
Ich mache mal kurz hier.
Package Updates.
Warum hängt das Community Repo?
Moment, gibt es das Community Repo überhaupt?
Ja doch, gibt es.
Ich muss bestimmt irgendwas in meiner Pack,
mein Config auskommentieren, was seit
5 Jahren oder so
erstmal kurz gucken,
schon Standard ist,
aber ich das nicht mitbekommen habe.
Lass mal kurz schauen.
Ah, guck mal, da gibt es eine Mirrorless Pack New
vom 1. Januar.
Warte mal, hier vielleicht
Pack.
Welches Linux?
Ach, by the way,
use ich, natürlich.
Lass mal kurz gucken, was ist denn hier der Unterschied?
Zwischen?
Was? Achso, ja.
Kaum, kaum.
Community.
Ich sehe da jetzt keinen großen Unterschied.
Testing.
Testing rein, Testing raus.
Extra.
Warte mal.
Die Diff-Darstellung ist immer so.
pp grame gibt es kein community repo mehr kann das sein
es gibt kein community repo mehr ok ja dann cpn wir einfach die pacman
konf pack new über die pacman konf drüber und gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert
Bam
Ach, by the way
Jetzt bin ich mir aber
Jetzt habe ich natürlich kein Backup mehr
Von alten gemacht, aber
Musste man da noch irgendwas einstellen?
Extra
Extra ist included
Nö, passt doch eigentlich, ist alles gut
So, jetzt machen wir mal Update
Ich glaube, ich habe schon seit zwei Monaten die VM-Nit.
Guck mal hier, 300 Packages.
Wobei, das heißt ja unter Archie Luxnix 300 Packages.
Das kann auch einfach innerhalb von zwei Tagen sein.
Da weiß der nicht.
Gestern habe ich es voll übertrieben, Leute.
Mir tut alles weh heute.
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, alles.
Aber ich merke es richtig in den Beinen.
und ich merke es auch
auf der Brust
jetzt nicht als Kreislauf mäßig
sondern weil das
Trikot da so dran gescheuert
hat den ganzen Tag
gestern habe ich es voll übertrieben
schönes Wetter
gestern war ich, passt mal auf, ich muss mal kurz
die App aufmachen
Garmin möchte mir die ganze Zeit
Garmin Connect Plus verkaufen, die können mich mal
wenn die anfangen
sollten
dass jetzt Features, die man kennt, auf einmal hinter irgendeiner komischen Abo-Paywall sind,
bei Uhren, die irgendwie 300 Euro plus kosten, da können die mich mal, dann gehe ich irgendwo anders hin.
So sehr verheiratet mit Garmin bin ich auch nicht.
Also ich war gestern Morgen 1 Stunde 40, relativ zügig spazieren, Zeug einkaufen und Kram machen hier,
1 Stunde 40. Dann war ich 46 Minuten Joggen. 7,14 Kilometer. Und dann war ich mittags nochmal 52 Kilometer Fahrradfahren.
Ich merke es mir
Und das, obwohl ich in letzter Zeit gar nicht mehr so viel gemacht habe
Ich konnte dann auch nicht mehr
Leute, zweite Hälfte von der Fahrradrunde
Habe ich richtig gemerkt, wie ich abgebaut habe
Meine Garmin App meint auch
Meine Body
Body Battery
Nenne ich das immer
Die war für die letzte halbe Stunde auf 1%
Das ist quasi komplett leer
Ich konnte nicht mal mehr als 100 Watt
Wenn ich über 100 Watt
Getreten habe in die Pedale
habe ich in den Oberschenkeln gemerkt,
konnte nicht mehr.
Welche Garmin? Ich habe eine
Garmin Forerunner
255. Gibt es 255S?
Dann habe ich so ein Teil, glaube ich.
255S. Klingt so.
Ja.
Also man kann sich
bei Uhren, die ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht mal das neuste
Modell, aber bei Uhren, die 200 Euro plus kosten,
dürfte man Basic
App-Funktionalität, denke ich,
durchaus kostenlos erwarten, oder was denkt ihr?
ich finde ich finde das ist nicht zu viel verlangt und wenn die jetzt anfangen hinter
garmin connect plus irgendwelche wichtigen funktionen zu verstecken dann gehe ich woanders
hin ich weiß nicht wohin aber irgendwo wo ich für 200 euro plus wenigstens basic app sachen kriege
er das ist noch billiger die gehen teilweise bis bis bis vierstellig glaube die teuren das
Gut, die teuren, die haben teilweise größere Displays, farbige Displays, haben schnellere Hardware, können beispielsweise Karten ordentlich anzeigen und sowas.
Das kann meine Garmin nicht.
Also meine Garmin kann keine Karten anzeigen.
Meine Garmin-Uhr kann, wenn du da beispielsweise einen GPS-Track drauf machst, der kann dir den Weg anzeigen, aber der kann dir halt keine Karte drumherum anzeigen.
Was ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so wild ist.
Zumut guckst du auf Komoot
Komoot wurde ja auch verkauft
Da
sind jetzt alle gespannt
ob der Investor es verkackt oder nicht
Der hat ja eine History von
Verkacken, ich weiß nicht was der Komoot
Investor noch alles gekauft hatte
Aber vieles davon ist ja ziemlich
abgekackt
So, jetzt machen wir nochmal die Jetplane Apps
Alter, guck mal hier
Bam, Update
Das wird jetzt richtig viel CPU-Last gleich verursachen.
Weil wir können es ja auch hier oben sehen.
Da habe ich noch nie was von gehört.
Es muss doch noch irgendwelche anderen Hersteller geben.
Wisst ihr, was mich auch ein bisschen nervt?
Dass die so...
Also das mag jetzt gar nicht mal an Garmin unbedingt selbst liegen.
dass sie teilweise sehr zurückhaltend sind, welche Optionen sie für App-Entwickler anbieten.
Und ich habe die Vermutung, das liegt daran, dass sie nicht wollen,
dass die App-Entwickler irgendwelche Sachen machen, die sie eigentlich machen wollen irgendwann mal.
Ja, zum Beispiel an meinem Fahrrad habe ich oben an den Griffen vom Lenker,
habe ich von von shimano so zwei knöpfe an den also an den da auch die schaltung
ist ja da hast du zwei shimano di2 buttons und so und was mit google los
ja genau guck hier oben hast du an den am lenker hast du zwei buttons da hast du
button das button oben und man würde jetzt ja eigentlich vermuten das ist
frei belegbar würde man jetzt denken so wenn man so klopft da oben hat nein ist
es aber nicht weil die leute bei garmin sich denken diese button funktionalität
da hat nur unsere firm wir exklusiv zugriff drauf nur unsere eigenen
settings irgendwelche app entwickler können button presses nicht abfangen
Das heißt, du kannst mit den DI2 Buttons eigentlich nichts großartig machen, außer Screens auf deinem Garmin changen.
Du kannst nämlich etwa einen Musiktrack vor oder zurück machen oder einfach custom belegen.
Ja, das naheliegendste Feature, einfach zwei Button.
Überleg mal, wie cool das wäre, du hättest zwei custom belegbare Buttons links und rechts.
Könntest sagen Long Press, Double Press, Single Press, Triple Press.
Stellt euch mal vor, im Jahr 2024 werden Buttons frei belegbar werden.
Danke für den Sub.
Das ist halt ein bisschen kacke.
So.
Acht, by the way.
Haben wir geupgradet.
Ah, guck mal.
Der Pilpo hat Hunger.
Erst Croissants
und jetzt, was ist denn das?
Wie heißt das? Loops oder so?
Boot Loops?
Wie nennt sich dieses Zeug?
zumindest kaffee es könnte auch tee sein ich bin ja gar kein kaffeetrinker und
das trotz trotz ich arbeite in der it und ich fahre fahrrad das sind eigentlich
zwei sachen wo beide seiten sehr auf kaffee stehen
das sind keine cornflakes cornflakes sind anders aus gut loop ich habe
letztens ein nummernschild gesehen dass das hätte fast gut sein können ja fast
fast gut. Das war
das Nummernschild
war irgendwie
65 oder sowas.
Also hier, irgendwie so.
Nummernschild. Ich weiß
ja gar nicht, was ist das eigentlich
für ein Nummernschild? Wo kommen die her?
Was?
Okay.
Und da habe ich gedacht,
da habe ich gedacht, warum
bitte schön nicht Cocker69?
Ja?
Das war der fast
Das Lummer-Chill war so close
Geht's heute wieder in den Kreisel-Crime
Ich mach den ganzen Tag Kreisel-Crime
Ihr seid bloß nicht dabei
Ich muss dir nach all der Zeit etwas berichten
Ich habe immer hingeschaut, wenn du gesagt hast, wir müssen
Was?
Ach so
Du weißt, wenn ich gesagt habe, ihr dürft jetzt beim Passwort
Passwort nicht gucken
Ja, das ist nicht schlimm, aber du musst versprechen, ab jetzt immer wegzugucken, okay?
Chat, immer wenn ich sage, nicht hingucken dürft, müsst ihr weggucken ab jetzt.
So, jetzt können wir die VM eigentlich wieder ausmachen, weil brauchen wir nicht.
Habe ich irgendwas, habe ich irgendwas, okay, dann ist gut, dann ist gut, dann wirst du nicht timeoutet.
So, ähm, habe ich irgendwas Wichtiges verpasst sonst noch?
Achso, ja, Mindfactory ist wieder am Start, habt ihr das mitbekommen? Mindfactory Pleite?
Also, Old News, ich weiß.
Mindfactory war insolvent und, oder war, oder ist, oder ich weiß nicht genau.
Zumindest sind die angeblich jetzt wieder unter den Lebenden.
So genau habe ich es nach der ersten Sache gar nicht mehr verfolgt.
Also Mindfactory war weg.
Wobei ich das...
Entra-ID-Monkey ist aller.
Wobei ich das gar nicht so genau verstehen kann, ehrlich gesagt.
Warum Mindfactory...
Ich habe das...
Vielleicht, wenn man sich damit etwas näher beschäftigt,
dann hätte man es vielleicht verstehen können.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, außer so grob drüber geguckt, habe ich nicht.
Ich konnte es irgendwie so beim Lesen, so beim Überfliegen nicht verstehen.
mein factory ist auch ein shop der ist seit jahren am start der muss auch gut
laufen also zumindest wenn man mal von mir aus geht ich habe da schon mehrere
pc generationen immer wieder wichtige und nicht billige teile bestellt bei
mein factory und allgemein ist da auch empfohlen und ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass mein factory zu wenig verkauft
das hat das konnte ich das konnte nicht verstehen einzige einzige was ich mir
vorstellen kann ist dass die zwar viel verkauft haben aber dank preis krieg so
bei online shops was hardware angeht einfach nicht genug pro teil verdient
haben übrigens ich muss hier auf aufhören
Chrome zu verwenden, weil Chrome
Adblock, also hier
Ublock, tut nicht mehr
in Chrome.
Das ist auch so eine Sache,
was sich die letzten
Monate, ein, zwei Monate
getan hat.
Jetzt war eine Frage an euch,
Chat. Verwendet ihr noch Chrome,
seitdem Ublock Origin nicht mehr geht?
Also,
sagen wir mal so, ich muss das anders formulieren.
Ich muss das anders formulieren.
verwendet ihr noch Chrome als euren Hauptbrowser für rumgucken den ganzen Tag, seit U-Block Origin nicht mehr funktioniert.
Weil ich verwende Chrome auch noch.
Ich verwende Chrome zum Beispiel für YouTube und für YouTube Musik und sowas und für Amazon Prime Videos und so Geschiss,
wo halt das in Chrome am besten funktioniert.
Ne, bald nicht mehr
Bald nicht mehr
Erstmal wurde es nur temporär
Und mittlerweile muss es angeblich dauerhaft sein
Aber Edge ist auch Chromium-based
Da weiß man nicht, wie lange das funktioniert
Also die einzige sinnvolle Alternative ist eigentlich Firefox
Ja, Brave sagt
sagt
bei ihnen ist ein adblocker mit drinnen
Ja
firefox macht komische privacy sachen wobei wenn man sich die marktung so
schlimm wird es da auch nicht sein ich meine ganz ehrlich wenn man chrome in kauf genommen hat dann sollte man auch mit den user
bedingungschance in firefox klarkommen
man könnte ja es gibt ja noch ein paar firefox forks
früher unter db an gab es immer noch ice weasel das war dann gefolgt da gefolgt der firefox weil es irgendwelche
Lizenzbedingungen erforderlich gemacht haben.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das immer noch der Fall ist.
Bei dir ist es noch aktiv?
Okay, ne, guck, bei mir ist es rausgeflogen
jetzt.
Ladybird gibt es auch noch, ja.
Aber die Browsersituation ist insgesamt
wirklich nicht schön gerade.
Weil
das ist halt ein... Oh Gott, was
habe ich denn hier auf? Alter, warum?
Warum um alles in der Welt habe ich
C++ offen?
Will mich mein Browser jebaiten, dass ich jetzt erstmal 20 Minuten C++ Rant starte zum Start des Streams oder was?
Warum werde ich hier so jebaited?
Wenn ich mir das angucke, kriege ich schon wieder Aggression und muss erstmal über das C++ Gremium los meckern.
Ne, ne.
Das machen wir erstmal, machen wir alles weg.
Sonst...
Ja, achso und Brother.
Brother hat es auch verkackt mit ihren Laserdruckerfirmen.
Ja, man kann jetzt keine Third-Party-Toner mehr nehmen, wo ich das gerade sehe.
Ich mache mal hier alles zu.
Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam.
So, und wir müssen jetzt, stimmt, stimmt, das haben wir früher auch immer gemacht,
gucken, was bei GitHub, was bei ShitHub so trendet die Woche.
Das machen wir jetzt.
Was habe ich denn da gerade gesehen?
Standards First Web Framework Taking HTML.
Gab es nicht mal eine Seite?
Minutes
also so Minuten
seit das letzte JavaScript Framework
veröffentlicht wurde
ja
heimlich C++ programmiert
ja ich gebe es zu
da hast du Glück
Du kannst mich auch länger nicht verfolgen.
Ich war ja gar nicht da.
Der gleiche Grund, warum ich jetzt auf Twitch
eine ganze Weile nicht aktiv war.
Ich kann es jetzt nicht so im Detail erzählen.
Das sind keine Beziehungsprobleme,
weil das schon immer wieder vermutet wurde.
Ich hatte ein paar andere Sorgen und Probleme,
die ich lösen musste.
Aber das meiste davon ist gefixt.
Eigentlich gibt es jetzt gar keine Ausrede mehr,
keine Videos zu machen.
Aber das ist erst gefixt seit ein paar Wochen.
Deswegen ist das heute auch der erste Stream am Sonntag seit langem.
Wir haben schon mal eins, zweimal die letzten paar Monate gestreamt, aber jetzt nicht so normales Zeug.
Lotto gewinnen, ja das wäre auch nicht schlecht.
Was ist denn los mit U-Block?
Chrome hat was an ihrer, ich versuche das mal möglichst high level zu beschreiben.
Chrome hat was an ihren Plugin-Bedingungen oder beziehungsweise an ihren Plugin-Schnittstellen geändert,
so dass Werbeblocker es besonders schwer haben.
Warum kann man sich überlegen, warum Google das nicht gerne mag mit Werbeblockern?
Amazon findet das bestimmt auch kacke mit Werbeblockern, weil ihr müsst euch mal überlegen,
genau, so heißt das, Manifest V3.
Die haben schon immer ein paar Anläufe genommen
Und da war der Shitstorm zu groß
Und die haben es wieder rückgängig gemacht
Aber diesmal ist es soweit, diesmal kommt das
Und macht Adblockern das Leben schwer
Deswegen wird es kein NewBlock Origin mehr geben
In der jetzigen Version für Chrome
Bleibt im Endeffekt nur
Firefox übrig
Als einziger großer verbreiteter Browser
Mit offener Plugin-Schnittstelle
Und selbst Firefox, finde ich
hat sie letzten jahre über ein bisschen verkackt und ein bisschen ihre stamm
userschaft aus den augen verloren nämlich hauptsächlich technik
interessierte hacker mensch also nicht nur aber zumindest die möglichkeiten
müssen da sein ja aber firefox ist das einzig sinnvolle zurzeit oder ein
firefox fork oder was vielleicht auch noch geht ist brave weil die handeln
ganz guten adblocker eingebaut bei ich bei denen immer nicht so genau weiß was
die sonst noch so machen, also keine Ahnung.
Ich bleib bei Firefox,
beziehungsweise bei Chromium, solange
U-Block Origin noch funktioniert.
Ja, es ist glaube ich wahrscheinlich wieder Zeit,
sich das mal anzugucken.
Für manche Sachen, wo es gar nicht anders geht,
ist vielleicht Chromium oder Chrome immer noch was,
wenn es da eh nicht viel Werbung gibt.
Aber wisst ihr, was mir auch echt auf den Keks geht?
Dass du bei Prime mittlerweile Werbung hast,
obwohl du halt Prime und Prime Video
und ganzes Gedöns eh bezahlst,
kriegst du Werbung. Und das war halt in Chrome
mit U-Block
auch weg. Und Chrome ist halt
der einzige Browser, der das gescheit abspielt.
Also,
hat
Firefox Microsoft 365
und iCloud Password-Safe
Möglichkeiten. Ich hab ehrlich gesagt
keine Ahnung, aber wenn Chrome das
kann mit Addons, wird es Firefox höchstwahrscheinlich
auch können.
Ne, es betrifft prinzipiell erstmal alle Chromium Sachen. Wenn jemand einen Chromium Fork Browser bereitstellt, dann können die sicherlich den Kram nachträglich wieder aktivieren und reinpatchen oder im Falle wie Brave das Ganze durch einen eigenen eingebauten Adblocker ersetzen.
Aber prinzipiell würde ich sagen, dass auch bei Chromium und generell Chrome-based, auch
Edge und sowas, Chrome-based Browsern die Zeit von alten Add-ons, die auf dem alten
Standard basieren, was halt uBlock Origin macht, gezählt sind.
Und also die einzige sinnvolle Alternative ist eigentlich sich jetzt an Firefox zu gewöhnen.
Bei Edge muss man mal gucken, aber ich denke auch, dass die Tage von U-Block Origin in Edge gezählt sind.
Ja und was kam in dem Video als Fazit raus? Wahrscheinlich auch, nehmt Firefox, schrägstrich Firefox-based Browser oder Brave, oder?
Safari
Der Internet Explorer unter den
Browsern im Jahr 2025
Safari
Also da weiß ich ja gar nicht
Da bin ich mir unflüssig
Was ich jetzt nerviger finden solle
Safari
Oder Chrome ohne Adblocker
Die Empfehlung war LibreVolv oder Brave
Siehst du, also genau das, was ich auch gesagt habe.
Firefox bzw. Firefox-based oder eben Brave.
Ja.
Also realistisch betrachtet wird es auf Firefox rauslaufen.
Wir könnten theoretisch schon anfangen und unsere ganzen Sachen hier mal auf Firefox umstellen.
Wobei, ich bin zu faul.
Ich will meine ganzen Browser-Tabs nicht konvertieren in Firefox.
So, wir gucken mal kurz, was auf Shithub diese Woche trendet.
Da muss man übrigens aufpassen.
Ich habe euch ja die Story schon ein paar Mal erzählt,
dass in meinem letzten Job der Azubi, der den Vortrag gehalten hat über das Shit-Repo,
dass wir Git immer Shit ausgesprochen haben.
Und da hat mir letztens jemand erzählt,
Max, das ist gar nicht so gut, das Jid auszusprechen, weil in irgendeiner, ich glaube auf Rumänisch oder so, würde Jid, würde Jude heißen.
Und das ist ja immer im Kontext von, wenn das Deutsche so eventuell herablassend verwendet, muss man aufpassen.
Monka, Monka Estheim, gesagt, okay, gut, irgendwelche Wörter wird es in jeder Sprache in irgendeiner Form geben.
das
das Beste, was mir dazu einfällt, ist
der Frazier
der hatte, er hat seine Online
seine Online-Charts, also in MMOs
also der Fabian
der hatte seine Online-Charts immer
irgendwas mit Yia
Yiaz und so genannt
online und Yara
und so und irgendwann hat er
sich mal Yara genannt
irgendwie so und das heißt ja auf Türkisch Schwanz
Das ist ihm dann auch erst aufgefallen, als die Leute ihn angeschrieben haben.
So nach dem Motto, warum heißt du Schwanz?
Also, ich meine, es gibt nur eine endliche Anzahl an Buchstabenkombinationen, die kurz und knackig ist.
Die wird in irgendeiner Sprache, fast jede Buchstabenkombination irgendwas bedeuten.
Wohl scanne 9 default ich weiß nicht
Shit tricks ist tatsächlich nicht so falsch ja
So also das ist mal gucken was die woche so trendet auf geht habe
YouTube Music
YouTube Music Desktop App
Das ist auch so ein Ding, wisst ihr?
Ich frage mich
Warum es das nicht einfach so gibt
Warum braucht da irgendein
Warum muss da irgendeiner an den Start kommen
Und wahrscheinlich TypeScript based
TypeScript view based
Auf der anderen Seite im Browser tut es auch gut
Eigentlich, eigentlich
Ich nehme das zurück, was ich gesagt habe
Warum eigentlich
Eine Desktop App
wegen adblocker ok aber das geht im browser ja auch
free simple fast interactive
ja ganz wisst ihr das ist auch so ein ding carplay finde ich ist total vernachlässigt von
apple ich habe ja auch mittlerweile ein auto was carplay und android auto heißt das ist das ist
wieder so typische google benahmung ja wisst ihr dass es apple in wir wisst ihr
dass es google auto und google automotiv gibt das ist total hängen geblieben
das eine ist das eine ist quasi das carplay von google und das andere ist
ein android explizit angepasst für
Car Entertainment Systeme.
Also, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe,
ist Google, beziehungsweise
Android Automotive, ist das
Android, was eben bei euch im Auto läuft,
wenn es Android Based ist.
Und Google Android Auto
oder so, ist quasi das Carplay
Gegenstück.
Also, nur
Microsoft macht es in der Benahmung besser.
Also, schlechter.
Die Autohersteller, ja gut, die wollen gerne ihren eigenen Schnitt machen, aber an den mangelnden Apps liegt das nicht unbedingt an den Autoherstellern.
Das liegt daran, dass die Pluginschnittstellen und das was möglich ist und das was zugelassen wird, künstlich beschränkt wird.
also sowohl google als auch apple sagt halt zum beispiel video apps und sowas
sind nicht erlaubt die während der fahrt gehen weil das lenkt die leute ab und
dann fahren die leute gegen den baum ja und das ganze zu jailbreak und custom
sachen das ist unnötig kompliziert also da ist eindeutig der hersteller dran
schuld nicht die autohersteller und ja dass so wenig apps carplay und sonst
was unterstützen ist dem wohl irgendwie auch geschuldet dass es nicht so weiß
nicht so nicht so beliebt ist ich habe keinen dicken bmw am start ich habe
einen fiat 500e am start das ding ist aber relativ modern innen drin
das einzige was mich da ein bisschen nervt ist dass die keine changelogs
haben leute wenn ihr mal wenn ihr mal in der fiat werkstatt die leute absolut zum
keck waiten bringen wollt dann müsst ihr nach changelogs für die firmware
updates fragen die wissen überhaupt nicht was ihr wollt von denen ich war
letztens in der werkstatt weil der fiat ist der meinung er muss er muss einmal
im jahr oder nach ich weiß nicht 300 kilometer oder so die die drei
kilometer ein bisschen sehr wenig nach 3000 km ich weiß nicht es gibt so
sachen entweder nach keine ahnung 3000 kilometern oder nach einem jahr will er
immer in die werkstatt ich mache das nicht immer punktgenau aber ab und zu
weil fiat selbst firma updates ot a nur für das main entertainment system
erlaubt ja das kann auch sein ich war oder 30.000 kann sei ich war ja 3000
wäre auch ein bisschen wenig ihr habt da schon recht zumindest fiat erlaubt also
normale updates über wlan oder ot halt über über mobilfunk nur für das
entertainment system die ganzen hardware dinger da drin die auch eine firma haben
die vielleicht geupdatet werden muss das können nur die in der fiat werkstatt
machen so und mir ist jetzt schon ein paar mal aufgefallen also paar mal ich
war zweimal oder so daher paar mal so ein paar mal aufgefallen dass sie sagen
ja sie haben für mehr update gemacht und das letzte mal habe ich die gefragt ja
Ja, okay, was hat sich denn geändert?
Äh, gibt es irgendwelche Changelogs, was es jetzt Neues gibt oder so?
Äh, ja, das kann ich Ihnen jetzt nicht sagen.
Das Witzige ist, ich glaube denen sogar, dass sie das nicht wissen.
Weil Fiat das selbst nicht...
Wisst ihr, wie schwierig das ist, irgendwelche Changelogs selbst für das Entertainment-System rauszubekommen?
Ne, das Ding updatest du, rebootest
Du siehst, okay, jetzt oben links
Ist die Schrift ein bisschen kleiner
Und du denkst dir, es muss doch von Fiat
Irgendein scheiß Changelog geben
Oder wenigstens mal eine Versionshistorie
Gibt es nicht
Gibt es nicht, du findest nichts gescheites
Bei Fiat
Also das ist wirklich voll für den Arsch
Wenn du das hier, hier, ich zeig es euch
Fiat Uconnect
Was guckt man denn? Changelog
Ja hier, vergiss es
Es gibt keine
Change Logs
Oh ja, Access denied, oh nice
Das ist halt voll für den Arsch, ganz ehrlich
Ach ja und
Meine Fiat Connected Services
Sind jetzt ausgelaufen
Die sind bloß 3 Jahre seitdem man das Auto
Und seitdem das Auto quasi das erste Mal eingeschaltet wurde
Sind die nur inklusive
Ich soll jetzt, glaube ich,
29 Euro oder so im Jahr noch bezahlen,
dass ich mein...
Haltet euch fest.
Ich glaube, es sind 29 Euro.
Ich glaube, ich soll 29 Euro im Jahr bezahlen,
dass ich jetzt
den Batteriestand in der App sehen darf.
Den Batteriestand
bei einem Elektroauto.
Nur mit Abo.
Da fällt mir nichts mehr zu ein, Alter.
Wir reden jetzt hier nicht irgendwie von Diebstahlsicherung oder irgendwie super krass GPS-Ortungsfeatures.
Wenn du da reinfährst, geht automatisch das Hof da aus oder sowas.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Wir reden von Akkustand.
Ladungen sind nie inklusive.
What the fuck?
Musst immer selbst bezahlen.
Warte mal, ich gucke gerade mal in die...
Moment, lass mich gerade mal in die App nachgucken.
Nicht, dass ich euch jetzt Mist erzähle.
Ähm, weil das ist auch, das ist auch mal wieder super unübersichtlich gemacht.
Ich kann irgendwie 50 Sachen abonnieren.
Manche Sachen includen andere Sachen.
Your account services are being updated.
This will be just a moment.
Just a moment heißt, die App ist gefreest.
Geil.
Nice, Fiat.
Die App ist einfach gefreest.
Es kam gerade ein Pop-Up, es wird geupdatet, jetzt ist die App gefreezed.
Also ich weiß nicht, ich habe den Eindruck, außer Tesla, und das weiß ich auch nur vom Hörensagen,
haben die ganzen Autohersteller echt ein bisschen reingeschissen, was Software und alles angeht.
Ich muss die App jetzt wirklich force beenden, um sie dann öffnen zu können.
Bei Tesla muss es aber der umgedrehte Fall sein.
Dort werden ja wohl manchmal Features über Firmware-Updates disabled.
Also zum Beispiel, was habe ich letztens gelesen, wurde bei Tesla disabled?
Die Rückfahrsensoren wurden disabled und jetzt geht es nur noch über Kamera oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen.
Okay, also.
Käufliche Pakete.
Connect Premium, Connect Plus.
Assistant.
Car, Entertainment
Navigation
Remote, Alert
Und MyAlert
What the hell, was wollt ihr
Alter
Was wollt ihr von mir
Ich glaube ich brauch
Ich glaube ich brauch MyCar
Und das kostet 29 Euro im Jahr, genau
Achso, das meinst du
Ja, das könnte ich mir irgendwann auch vorstellen
Dass die Ladeklappe nicht mehr aufgeht, wenn du kein Abo hast
Hotspot-Nutzung musst du zusätzlich kaufen beim Fiat
Don, Dankeschön für den Sub
Pog
Trigger das Abo nur eine Anzeige mit True Falls
Ja macht es, weil
Wenn man selbst mit Addons
Über die API abfragt, ist der Akkustand mit dabei
Also in meinem Home Assistant
Ist der Akkustand immer noch drin
aber in der app wird es nicht angezeigt also im prinzip bezahlt
du 9 und sollst du 29 euro nur bezahlen dass der akkustand in der app angezeigt wird
bmw hat sitzheizung as a service das weiß ich das wird immer erzählt ich habe nie
nachgeguckt ob das wirklich so ist ist das wirklich so dass sie diese zeit so eingebaut
haben und das nur per abo ging ja ich werde mich wird es mich wird es in der heutigen zeit beim
besten willen nicht wundern du bist da war nach einem feinmechaniker werkzeug ja habe ich habe
ich habe ich wenn du bist wenn du ein bisschen kohle ausgeben willst das hier das ist gut und
wenn es in etwas wenn es noch etwas universeller sein darf wenn es noch etwas universeller sein
darf aber wenn jetzt nicht unbedingt made in germany high quality brauchst kannst du auch
so ein fix set kaufen da hast du den vorteil du hast du hast zwar nicht so schöne griffe und nicht
so schöne dreh und dinger und alles aber hier bei dem fixe toolkit hast du ein das ist nicht
das Richtige. Das meine ich nicht. Das ist das
Falsche. Das meine ich nicht.
Das ist, das ist das, ähm...
Das hier meine ich.
Wobei, ich bilde mir ein, bei mir
sind mehr Sachen drin. Da hast
du halt so einmal so einen Schrauber und
aber so ziemlich Bits für alle möglich abgedrehten
Sachen. Äh, ich muss
mal kurz bei mir reingucken. Ich bilde mir ein,
bei mir sind mehr Bits drin, als man hier sieht.
Ist das das richtige Set?
Pass mal auf, warte mal, ich muss noch kurz reingucken.
Ich hab das hier liegen.
Also, ja, bei mir sind deutlich mehr drin.
Bei mir sind allein schon 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 Bits in der unteren Reihe.
Also das ist es schon mal nicht.
Ach, das gibt es in verschiedenen Größen.
Da muss man gucken.
So Dinger gehen auch klar.
So Dinge gehen auch klar.
Aber wenn du was wirklich qualitativ hochwertiges haben willst, wo du bei den meisten Sachen mit klarkommst,
nimmst du das Vera Feinmechaniker Set.
Das kostet halt mehr.
Dafür kannst du angeben, dass du ein Vera Set hast.
Also mit beiden Sachen kannst du eigentlich nicht so viel falsch machen
Ganz ehrlich
So cool das ist
Und so gut die Dinge in der Hand liegen
Beim PC schrauben ist das jetzt nicht ganz so wild
Ja bei den anderen
Also bei Bits für einen Akkuschrauber
Zum Beispiel
Da würde ich sagen da macht es durchaus Sinn
Sich qualitativ was hochwertiges zu kaufen
weil da habe ich schon oder auch für auch für auch bits die die fürs fahrrad oder so brauchst
da habe ich schon dinge die sind dann halt haben sich verdreht und sowas aber ganz ehrlich beim
schrauben am pc wird jetzt in der regel nicht so viel kraft da rein hauen müssen dass ich da auch
ein bisschen günstigeren sachen was was verdreht also ein fix set ist allgemein nicht schlecht zu
haben ich habe ja viel mehr werkzeug als ich eigentlich brauche und trotzdem fehlt ein
manchmal was ich benutze das i fix it gerne wenn ich nicht genau weiß was für
schrauben am start sind ja wenn man jetzt irgendwie mal nachgucken muss oder
das irgendwie irgendwelche geräte aufmachen muss die nicht dafür gedacht
sind also dass das i fix it echt ganz gut
ich kenne keinen der seine vera schraubendreher als gebraucht verkauft
aber das ist gut das zeug egal welches davon nur welches davon du nimmst kann
man sich alles gut, kann man alles gut
mit was machen.
So, also,
was ist denn das hier überhaupt? Wir wollen ja mal gucken,
was diese Woche trendet. New trendet.
Nicht zu verwechseln mit
View. Warum
müssen die Dinge auch noch so ähnlich heißen?
Standards first
Web Framework taking HTML to the
absolute peak. Okay, warum sollte ich jetzt
dieses Web Framework verwenden
anstelle von React
Angular, Vue, Svelte, jQuery, HTMLX, React und was es nicht alles noch für 1000 Sachen gibt.
Warum ist das jetzt viel besser?
Lighter than a React Button.
Aha.
Das ist more efficient.
Aber ich weiß trotzdem nicht, warum ich das verwenden sollte.
Warum?
Ah, weil es auf Bann basiert.
Ich habe doch gerade Bann gelesen.
Ach ne.
Eisflieg, danke schon für den Sub.
Exzellente Subscriptions hier.
So, also was trennt ihr die Woche?
eine YouTube Music Desktop App,
wo der Chat mir gesagt hat, dass das anscheinend doch ganz praktisch ist,
wo ich mich gerade noch gefragt habe, wer braucht das?
Git-Diagramme.
Shit-Diagrams.
Wisst ihr, das ist schon mal wieder aus meiner Sicht
eine Fail-Read-Me,
wenn man keine
Bilder von einem Diagramm hat.
Oder ist das...
Moment, ich habe nichts erzählt.
Ich glaube, das...
Ich glaube, das ist das.
Achso.
Ach.
Das ist nicht um Diagramme im Markdown zu malen, sondern das ist quasi Dependencies irgendwie.
Aha.
Okay, warum nicht? Das klingt doch ganz nützlich.
Also doch nicht. Doch kein Mist.
MCP. Das ist irgendwelches Machine Learning Gedöns.
Fragt mich nicht. Keine Ahnung.
WhatsApp Web Multi Device API.
Ach, da kann man mit Go WhatsApp Messages schicken.
Hat das irgendeiner reverse-engineert?
NVM Node Version Manager.
Das trennt es zurecht, das ist sehr praktisch.
Man kann mehrere Node.js Versionen parallel installieren und sowas.
Ja, und auch in Zeiten von Docker Images oder Containern ist das teilweise noch ganz nützlich.
ich habe übrigens letztens ein bisschen mit nix us die nicht nicht mit nix us mit dem nix package
manager rum gebastelt und mir ganz schnell drauf gekommen das ist für meine zwecke irgendwie
aufwand ich werde es ich wollte mir so eine entwicklungsumgebung für sp 32 basteln mit nix
Also jetzt nicht irgendwie im Container oder so, sondern mit dem Nix Package Manager.
Und da ist mir aufgefallen, dass du ESP-IDF gar nicht gescheit installieren kannst mit Nix.
Es gibt ein extra Package dafür auf GitHub, was aber auch wieder ein paar Probleme hat.
Also, use your NeoVim like using Cursor AI.
Oh ja, Cursor, Cursor.
Die Vibe-Coders sind am Start.
Das ist auch so ein Wort, Alter.
Ich finde das grausam.
Any Vibe Coders?
AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, es hört ja gar nicht mehr auf, AI!
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
No Description?
Ah!
Gekommritz am Start.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Ich finde mein
Ich finde mein E-Mode dafür
Okay, dann lass uns das mal kurz übersetzen
Translate
Konnte man nicht sagen
Chatbot konnte man nicht irgendwie
Achso, das ist Firefox
Kann Firefox nicht standardmäßig übersetzen?
Weiß nicht, aber
Translate
Okay, das ist natürlich
Bypass of Discord
und YouTube Blogs
Achso, okay, das ist, weil man aus Russland da nicht gescheit drauf zugreifen kann
anscheinend, aber wisst ihr was?
Ich weiß nicht, wie vertrauenswürdig
ich das finde
Ein Projekt mit russischer Readme
die als erstes eine Warning hat, dass es
Antivirus triggern könnte, aber das nicht schlimm ist
Richtet sich aber eh nur
russische Anwender von russischen Anwendern.
Also ja, nichts was
uns irgendwie betrifft.
AI, Rust Desk.
AI. Ist ja schlimm.
Es ist ja wieder 50. Es ist mal wieder so weit.
50% ist AI.
Gucken wir schnell nochmal Today durch.
Ist ja irgendwas Spannendes hier.
AI, AI, AI, AI.
Alles AI.
Ah, nicht ganz.
Music Free. China-Chinesen-Kram.
alles klar gucken wir uns jetzt auch noch mal an was sie so treiben scannt man lieber
nicht den qr code man weiß ja was dahinter ist translate to english
musik free in the app market has nothing to do with the software
Plugin Customized Ad-Free Music Player
that currently only supports Android
and Harmony OS.
Okay, wahrscheinlich
eine sehr legale
Music Streaming App.
Die China-Chinesen sind auch am Start, ja.
Terraform Provider AWS.
Warum trendet das überhaupt?
Das ist so ein Standardding mittlerweile.
Okay, 10 Sterne reichen schon.
10 Sterne reichen schon zum Trenden?
Es wird mal Zeit, dass wir auch trennen.
Aber dazu müsste ich erstmal wieder was basteln.
Übrigens, der Fiat Champ,
den braucht man nicht mehr.
Es gibt mittlerweile Forks.
Es gibt mittlerweile Forks vom Fiat Champ.
Ähm
Es gibt mittlerweile Forks vom Fiat Champ
Die das
Fixen, das heißt ich muss noch nicht mal
Meinen eigenen Camper fixen
Und kann es trotzdem weiterverwenden
Das ist nicht nice
Okay
Es trennt nur AI-Kram, juckt mich nicht
Hm
So, Chat.
Gibt es sonst noch irgendwas Spannendes,
worüber wir reden müssen?
Sonst gucken wir uns jetzt einfach ein paar, zum Aufwachen,
ein paar Sachen auf YouTube an.
Was haben wir denn hier?
South Korea is over.
Oh, das klingt aber sehr nach Apokalypse, ey.
Was machen die Stonks?
Die Stonks fallen.
Und zwar richtig.
Ich mach mal kurz Scalable auf.
Tekken geht voll an mir vorbei.
Also meine Stongs sind jetzt...
Super, also...
Ich seh's gar nicht.
Also die sind innerhalb von einem Monat...
Von...
Also die ETF-Stongs...
Die sind innerhalb von einem Monat...
Von...
Wie viel ist denn das jetzt genau? Scalable zeigt das irgendwie nicht richtig an.
Ich würde sagen, von 68.000 Euro irgendwie auf 58.000 Euro oder so gefallen.
Aber ich bin auch gerade am überlegen,
ob ich nicht einfach gucke, ob das nicht noch ein bisschen fällt
und dann kaufe ich einfach nochmal was.
Genau.
Also, ganz so
stonksig sehen die Stonks
gerade nicht aus.
Was haben wir denn auf YouTube,
was wir uns heute angucken können?
South Korea is over.
Das klingt sehr nach Weltuntergang.
Surviving on call at Amazon.
Realistisch.
Okay, realistisch.
Gucken wir mal, wie realistisch das ist.
Ob es nicht irgendwie
wir sitzen den ganzen Tag nur beim
Tischkicker spielen ist.
Dann haben wir
Er trainiert KI. Projekt und Lohn
eines Data Scientists am Fraunhofer
Institut. Okay, das können wir uns auch angucken.
Dann haben wir noch My Favorite
Homelab. Weiß ich nicht, ob das so wird.
Perfect Home Server.
Können wir mal gucken. Mal schauen, was uns
YouTube noch empfiehlt. Ich habe übrigens, wie ihr
vielleicht seht, ich habe mal ein paar Tabs
geschlossen. Also ich habe alle Videos,
die irgendwie schon seit drei Monaten offen sind,
habe ich einfach mal zugemacht.
Also so, weiß nicht, 50
Tabs oder so habe ich jetzt einfach mal geschlossen,
weil ich mir gedacht habe, wir kommen da eh nie
dazu und gucken uns das eh nie an.
Aber für alle
Multiple Tabs Enjoyer
hier habe ich noch ein paar.
Also es ist nicht so, als hätten wir zu wenig
Tabs.
Die
64 GB RAM müssen ja irgendwie
sich, das Schlimme ist die 64 GB
RAM, gell, die
wo ist denn das jetzt überhaupt hier, da.
die werden noch nicht mal groß benutzt
und dass die wirklich,
dass die 38,6 GB RAM
überhaupt used haben,
das liegt zum größten Teil daran,
dass Windows sehr großzügig
sich einfach mal RAM gönnt,
für den Fall der Fälle, dass da was kommen könnte.
Also es würde wahrscheinlich ohne Problem mit 16 GB RAM
auch laufen und
meine VM, die
unnötig viele
Ressourcen hat, ich meine, meine VM kriegt
24 GB RAM und hat glaube ich
8 CPU-Kerne.
Ich würde vor allem die einfach im Hintergrund
idelt gerade.
Halbes Internetbrowser.
Genau.
Macht Teams auf. Oh, das wird's kritisch.
Da wird's kritisch langsam.
Seht euch mal vor, ich würde Teams aufmachen
und vielleicht noch 1, 2 Elektron-Notiz-Apps.
Erstmal 4 Ggramm.
Pro App. Mindestens.
Und Teams noch mehr.
Ja, nur wenn ich sie reloaden.
Nur wenn ich die Tabs reloaden.
Also, vorher auch nicht.
So.
Da gucken wir uns doch jetzt mal was an.
Ups.
Ich versuche gerade auf dem zweiten Bildschirm irgendwie meine Windows...
Alter, mein Windows leckt wie sonst was auf dem zweiten Bildschirm gerade.
Was ist da los?
Egal.
So, dann gehen wir jetzt mal auf YouTube.
und gucken wir mal, mit was fangen wir denn an?
Gucken wir uns mal das an.
Er trainiert KI-Modelle.
Projekt und eines Data Scientists am Fraunhofer-Institut.
Übrigens, jetzt wo ich gerade...
Irgendwie musste ich da gerade an unsere Azubis denken.
Zwei Azubis.
Wir hatten letztens so eine Abteilungs...
größere Abteilungsversammlung, wo alle da waren.
Waren auch zwei Physi-Azubis am Start.
Also bei jetzt...
bei einer neuen Arbeit, ja.
auf der alten habe ich mich ja regelmäßig um die Azubis
gekümmert, auf der neuen Arbeit ist es selten
der Fall, aber immerhin irgendwie
muss ich das halbwegs
hinbekommen, weil selbst da darf ich mich
auch um Azubis kümmern
anscheinend mache ich das ganz
brauchbar, zumindest
habe ich da mit zwei Azubis geredet bei uns
und die meinten ernsthaft, müsst ihr euch mal
vorstellen
wenn die Sachen einbauen im
Rechenzentrum, das machen die selten
weil auch nur wenn sie in den Teams sind und sonst was
Die haben einen elektronischen Hebekran für Server-Hardware und einen Akkuschrauber.
Und da kam ich mir ein bisschen vor, wie so Opa Max erzählt vom Krieg.
Und hab mir gedacht, bei uns, wir hatten nix.
Bei uns gab's das alles nicht.
Wir haben Playcenter noch mit Muskelkraft gehalten.
und der form halber weil es immer so viele als irgendwie immer noch so viele leute nicht kennen
oder noch oder nicht mehr das ist ein play center
das fette teil hier und die lüfter die abgehen wenn du startest ja also ist 88 oder 12 oder
so weiß ich ja wie hoch das war richtig richtig fette schwere kisten und die waren sogar schwer
ohne plates drin also hier jeder jedes jedes ding was ihr hier vorne seht ja jedes dieser dinge hier
ist ein computer quasi ein rechner das war mal eine zeit lang relativ beliebt dass man eben
möglichst viel hardware in seine schränke rein bekommt du hast quasi ein komplett eigenständiger
computer mit rahmen cpu mainboard allem drauf wurde quasi so als plate reingeschoben ich weiß
12 oder so ging glaube ich in 1 rein oder lass mal 10 1 2 3 4 5 8 9 10 11 12 ja
Das kennen die leute heute auch nicht mehr
Sagen wir hatten nichts
Mit akkuschrauber ich weiß ich bin mir echt nicht sicher ob so eine gute idee ist server mit akkuschrauber volle pulle bis bis bis die schraube
zerspringt quasi da rein zu pressen
in der Regel brauchst du es nicht, weil Server kommen ja auf
eine Schiene drauf
und wenn du die mit einem Schraubendreher und von Hand
wieder abschrauben kannst, ist glaube ich auch nicht verkehrt
aber die sind da wirklich mit elektronischem
Hebekram und
Akkuschrauber am Start
die haben wahrscheinlich
haben die bestimmt sogar Sicherheitsschuhe
an, ja, könnte ich mir durchaus
vorstellen
Da muss ich aber aus eigener Erfahrung sagen, also nicht von meinem Fuß, sondern von dem, was ich gesehen habe, bei einem Rechenzentrumsumzug.
Sicherheitsschuhe sind sinnvoll bei einem Rechenzentrumsumzug.
Ein Kollege von mir ist damals einen 2HE HP DL380, frag mich nicht, welche Generation, auf den Fuß gefallen.
so auf aus so ein teil hier in der richtung war das so aus tragehöhe also was für sich 130 so
als ob es einmal aus 1 meter 30 1 meter 40 höhe ist dem so ein ding auf den fuß gefallen der
hatte keine sicherheitsschuhe an der merkt das heute noch der war erst mal zwei wochen weg weiß
ich was alles im arsch war am fuß aber wenn ihr so ein ding wenn ihr so ein ding mit der kante
auf dem fußfeld ohne sicherheitsschuhe das ist auf jeden fall nicht angenehm und sicherlich
auch schädlich das merkt er heute noch also es ist nicht alles was man früher nicht gemacht hat
unsinnig zum beispiel sicherheitsschuhe sind mit sicherheit sind nicht wenn man selber umzieht und
vier um trägt jetzt im server gut ehrlich gesagt ich glaube der server der hat es wahrscheinlich
überlebt außer die festplatten und bei selbst die festplatten wahrscheinlich hat die dinger waren
damals extrem robust also da hat sie teilweise hardware du hast das gefühl die konnte aus dem
zweiten stock aus dem fenster schmeißen dann wieder ein hochtragen einbauen die gegen immer
noch also das muss man echt sagen gerade die alte ibm hardware also noch vor lenovo zeiten
die waren wirklich echt hat die waren richtig massiv das war auch kein plastik das ist aber
hier noch noch lenovo kam das war auch kein plastik das war noch das war noch
wirklich in drin war viel metall
er so dinger zum beispiel ja da war viel metall das hier auch kein plastik auch
wenn es wie plastik aussieht ist auch metall und die dinger waren vga
übrigens immer noch sehr verbreitet bei server hat wer mittlerweile gibt es da
auch schon welche die haben was haben denn eigentlich aktuelle server
Hauptsächlich Displayport wahrscheinlich.
Aber ein VGA werden die auch alle noch haben.
VGA ist so der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner.
Das macht auch Sinn, dass die Server das haben.
Weil es gibt viele Inter-AZ-Verkabelungen.
Beispielsweise wenn du so einen Technikraum hast,
wo du dann per Konsole dich an die Server stöpselst.
Das ist halt auch VGA.
Die Dinger waren massiv stabil.
Also mich würde es nicht wundern,
wenn du so einen Server aus dem zweiten Stock in den Garten schmeißen könntest.
jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt auf Beton oder so,
aus dem zweiten Stock in den Garten
runterschmeißen könntest, auf
die Wiese, dann
wieder unter den Arm nehmen, einbauen, anschließend,
dann geht noch.
Nee, USB-C werden die wenigsten haben.
Ich kenne mich bei aktueller Server, also wirklich bei
topaktueller Server, hat man nicht mal so gut aus, aber ich glaube
nicht, dass es USB-C schon ist.
Für Displays, glaube ich nicht.
Und ich gehe ganz stark davon aus,
ein VGA werden die immer noch haben.
OGA ist so
Evergreen
Wisst ihr, was Server teilweise noch
Für Grafikkarten verbaut haben
ATI Rage 3D Pro
Sind da teilweise noch drin
Das ist Grafik Hardware von
Nee
Whatever
Grafik Hardware von
Von 1900
sonst wann ist da teilweise noch drinnen.
Also,
Grafik, Grafik,
so, also,
wir wollten uns ja hier angucken,
wie viel Grafik, ich glaube 4 oder 8 MB
oder sowas, aber für eine Konsole reicht's.
Die Serverhersteller
sind halt immer recht
konservativ.
Im Umstellen ihrer Sache.
Weil die wissen halt.
Dass es funktioniert.
Ja und wenn es funktioniert.
Dann.
Dann funktioniert es halt.
Und dann wollen die das nicht ändern.
Ne sowas suche ich.
Ja also sowas suche ich.
Allerdings on board ist das ja.
So also jetzt gucken wir uns mal an.
Was was was was verdient der data scientist
Wir müssen erst mal die lautstärke wieder richtig einstellen
Wo wir maschinen haben an denen wir auch forschen für den volksmund würde man sagen ich bin
Experte machen einfach volle pulle lautstärke laut auf der virtuellen maschine
Wir sind jetzt in der Maschinenhalle, wo wir Maschinen haben, an denen wir auch forschen.
Für den Volksmund würde man sagen, ich bin KI-Experte.
Genau, das Modell liegt quasi in der Cloud auf der virtuellen Maschine.
Bestimmt Azure und Microsoft only, geht uns, hä?
Besser Schutz vor einem Hackerangriff, einfach noch eine AS400-Maschine am Laufen haben.
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, ist AS400, nee, DS war Storage, oder?
oder ist AS400
oder ist das ein Mainframe?
Ah, das ist, okay.
Ja.
Genau.
Das ist diese Konsole, die so ein
Fadenkreuz teilweise hat.
Ja.
Find ich auch geil, bei uns auf der Arbeit, ne,
manche Großarmer zählen so nach dem Motto,
oh, wir sind jetzt, wir haben jetzt alles
Services in die Cloud gepackt und das läuft bei uns jetzt
alles in der Cloud. Ja, aber im Hintergrund
steht noch eine uralte IBM-Host rum.
So stelle ich mir das nicht vor, alle Services sind in der
Cloud. Ja, geil, irgendwelche
Sachen, die auf den Host zugreifen, die sind in der Cloud
schön und gut.
Das ist auch so was,
so eine Maschine für
zum G... Das ist wirklich... Leute,
wenn ihr mal beschissene Lizenzmodelle
sehen wollt, es ist nicht nur Oracle
und SAP und sowas die beschissenen
Lizenzmodelle
haben.
Wenn ihr ein IBM
Mainframe habt,
also ich sage euch das jetzt
besten Wissens und gewiss, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das
immer noch so ist, ja.
Innen gibt es da auch
so, genau, da gibt es ein Bild von,
ne, das ist busy klein.
Gibt es das vielleicht auch in
größer irgendwie? Wow, fuck.
Das ist mir jetzt zu...
Und zumindest dieser Rechner, den kauft ihr zwar, aber der gehört euch nicht.
Hier, genau. Der gehört euch nicht.
Ihr kauft den, ihr betreibt den, ihr bezahlt den Strom, aber Rechenleistung da drauf müsst ihr mieten.
Da hat sich IBM einfach gedacht, Big Stonks, wir wollen Geld machen.
und das heißt, wenn ihr Rechenzeit
beziehungsweise, nee, das stimmt ja gar nicht.
Das stimmt nicht.
Das ist falsch. Ich hab's euch falsch rum erzählt.
Ihr kauft nicht,
das stimmt überhaupt nicht, was ihr,
ihr kauft nicht Rechenzeit, das wär ja noch okay.
Ihr bezahlt CPU-Kerne.
Also ihr kauft euch so ein Ding
und dann müsst ihr quasi
für die CPU-Kerne da drinnen
Geld bezahlen,
einfach, dass ihr sie habt.
Das heißt, immer wenn das Ding eidelt, kostet es unnötig Geld.
Weil ihr bezahlt den CPU-Kern und ihr bezahlt nicht die Zeit.
Und dementsprechend versuchen die alle immer, ihre IBM-Großrechner möglichst auszulasten.
Mit allem möglichen Shit.
Ja, also das sind auch wirklich Lizenzgebühren und Sachen aus der Hölle, so diese Geschichte.
Und die Admins dafür sterben langsam aus.
Kennt irgendjemand einen Physi oder Fachinformatik Anwendungsentwicklung oder irgendwie irgendeiner, der seine Ausbildung in den letzten 10 Jahren abgeschlossen hat und wirklich sich noch auf Mainframe und sagen wir mal sowas wie Kobol oder Mainframe Java Gedöns spezialisiert? Also mir fällt keiner ein.
die jüngste
Server-Administratorin
die ich kenne, die das
macht, also
Server-Administratorin, das ist
eine, die hat mir die Ausbildung gemacht
2007 und die ist
danach
das ist die jüngste, die ich kenne, die ist
danach in Richtung Mainframe-Cobol-Entwicklung
gegangen, 2007
also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
das wird eine der letzten gewesen sein ja
okay fangen wir noch vorne gucken jetzt ich mache immer 30.000 unterbrechung
bei den videos wo wir wo wir bei lizenzen nutzt ihr vor allem oder wechselt
ihr nein wir benutzen vor allem jetzt mich privat oder meinst du bei mir auf
der Arbeit. Also im Business Enterprise Umfeld kann man
denke ich zu 90% sagen, die Unternehmen, die wirklich
richtig deep in VMware gewesen sind, auch mit geschultem
Personal und lizenziertem Gedöns und lizenzierter Software, die nur dafür
und hier und da, die werden höchstwahrscheinlich auch bei VMware bleiben.
Weil das Ökosystem um VMware so riesig ist,
uns keiner sich den Wechsel auf Proxmox oder andere Sachen zutraut.
Und ich bin mir auch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht sicher, ich habe jetzt von Virtualisierung ist jetzt nicht so unbedingt mein Steckenpferd, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es immer noch genug Sachen aus dem VMware Umfeld gibt, was man so nicht eins zu eins in Proxmox betreiben kann.
Weil VMware ist ja nicht nur die Virtualisierungsplattform, da ist ein riesen Gedöns von Backup, Automatisierungsplattformen, irgendwelche Portalgedöns, Securitygedöns und alle möglichen Krempel zusätzlich drumherum. Das ist ja ein riesen undurchsichtiges Ökosystem VMware. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, das tut es einfach so. Wenn man so tief da in VMware drin ist, tut es das mit Proxmox einfach nicht.
Deswegen denke ich, die meisten Unternehmen, die wirklich seit Jahren oder Jahrzehnten wirklich schon so weit in VMA drin sind, sich darauf eingeschossen haben, die werden auch die Pille schlucken und mehr bezahlen oder andere Lizenzgebühren ertragen müssen und weiter bei VMA bleiben.
Ist jetzt auch kein Verlust für die Menschheit, wenn Shitrix nicht funktioniert, aber für viele Unternehmen ist es halt Ausschlusskriterium.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns aber wirklich das
VIT an.
Ich würde mal sagen, ich bin ein KI-Experte.
Genau, das Modell liegt quasi in der
Cloud auf der virtuellen Maschine.
Wie findest du dein Gehalt?
Boah, echt schwierige Frage.
Boah, echt schwierige Frage. Also,
ich kann
sagen, wie ich mein Gehalt finde.
Also, ich muss...
Okay, ich muss das auf zwei Sachen sagen. Das klingt jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
fies.
Also, eigentlich ist es fast schon zu viel für das, was man macht.
Wenn man das vergleicht mit Leuten, die wirklich teilweise 12 Stunden am Stück,
was für den Fortbestand der Menschheit und für die Gesundheit anderer Leute tun,
ist das, was ich kriege, viel zu viel.
Ansonsten, wenn du mich mal unabhängig davon, von meinen, wie soll ich sagen,
von meinen so ethisch-moralischen Einschätzungen sagst, würde ich sagen,
ist es super, komme ich gut mit aus,
freue mich, dass ich
den Job habe, auch
unter den Bedingungen und
mehr nehme ich immer.
Gegen mehr sage ich nie was.
Hi zusammen,
mein Name ist Henrik und ich arbeite als
Data Scientist an einem Fraunhofer-Institut
in Aachen und beschäftige mich viel
mit künstlicher Intelligenz in der Produktion.
Guten Morgen,
So ein Chip in die HR-Abteilung interessiert das überhaupt nicht. Also wenn schon, interessiert das mein Chef, wenn ich das nächste Mal sage, ich will mein Geld haben. Aber was im Vertrag steht, steht halt nur mal im Vertrag drin und viele Anpassungen passieren auch automatisch.
Das Gute ist, und das haben die richtig nice gemacht, ich bin mir nicht sicher, welcher Tarifvertrag für uns gilt. Also für mich gilt kein Tarifvertrag, ich habe einen außertariflichen Vertrag, aber die außertariflichen Verträge orientieren sich bei den jährlichen Erhöhungen immer auch an den Tarifverträgen, weil, hat mir mein Chef letztens erklärt, macht auch eigentlich Sinn, moin Wartungsfenster, macht auch eigentlich Sinn,
Weil, wenn man immer nur Tariferhöhungen für die Tarifverträge macht, dann überholen irgendwann die Tarifverträge die außertariflichen Verträge. Stellt euch vor, man startet außertariflich mit 120.000 Euro im Jahr und die Tarifverträge gehen bis zu 80.000 Euro im Jahr.
Das geht jetzt ein paar Jahre und die würden nur die Tarifverträge anpassen, dann hast du irgendwann die Tarifverträge mehr als die außertariflichen Verträge. Deswegen werden bei uns die außertariflichen Verträge immer mehr oder weniger entsprechend zu den Tarifverträgen angehoben.
Das heißt, ich kriege alle paar Jahre irgendwie 5, 6 Prozent, ohne dass ich was machen muss, mehr, weil die Tarifverträge mehr kriegen. Dazu gibt es noch Budget, was die Chefs verplanen können. Also ich kann mich da echt nicht beschweren. Ganz ehrlich, ich würde die Arbeit auch für weniger machen.
... ist, analysiere ich Daten aus der Produktion, um bessere Entscheidungen zu treffen.
Besser im Sinne von dem, was ich optimieren möchte.
Ich kann Kosten optimieren, ich kann Zeiten optimieren.
Und Methoden der künstlichen Intelligenz sind Werkzeuge, die wir benutzen,
um eben die Daten zu analysieren und Vorhersagen zu machen.
Okay, lass uns das mal kurz... Sekunde, Leute.
Irgendwas hat mein... Ich muss euch mal kurz muten.
Zack.
Okay, jetzt geht's.
Irgendwie hat mein Mikrofon gerade ein bisschen rumgespackt.
Also was muss er heute machen?
Aufgaben für heute.
Übergabe KI-Projekt, Vorbereitung, Presentation, Industrieprojekt, E-Mails.
Ja, E-Mails ist immer die beste Ausrede.
Ja und, was machst du gerade?
Ich lese Mails.
Und um nicht den Klassiker zu vergessen.
Und Max, wie sieht's aus?
Da sind wir dran.
Ich nehme das mit, da sind wir dran gerade.
Oh nein, Tossmusik.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es...
Aktuell habe ich ein größeres Forschungsprojekt und zwei kleinere Industrieprojekte.
Die Herausforderung in unserem Job ist vor allem die Verantwortung, die man in den Projekten bekommt.
Also sehr früh wird man in Projektleitungen...
Ich habe jetzt eine ernst gemeinte Frage an euch. Ich lasse den Satz noch fertig sprechen.
Also das hier nochmal.
So, jetzt.
Gibt es wirklich Leute, die das gerne machen?
Projektleitung ist so ziemlich das Schlimmste, was ich mir vorstellen kann.
du kriegst Anschiss von deinen Leuten aus dem Projekt
die sind am meckern
und du kriegst das Gemeckere ab
von den Leuten, die das Projekt haben wollen
Projektleitung ist glaube ich so ziemlich
das Schlimmste, was ich mir vorstellen könnte
ich weiß, dass es Leute gibt, die das freiwillig machen
aber ich kann es nicht verstehen
dass es Leute gibt, die das freiwillig machen
ich hab das
also auf der alten Arbeit
hab ich auch immer gesagt, nee geh weg
wenn irgendwie einer damit ankam.
Auf der neuen Arbeit wollte das bisher noch keiner,
was aber auch richtig ist, weil
irgendwelche random Technikleute
fragen, willst du nicht mal Projektleitung machen?
Macht ja eh keinen Sinn. Die haben Leute dafür,
die auch mehr Ahnung haben als ich. Ich würde
es schlecht machen und ich würde es auch gar nicht
machen wollen.
Ja, genau, und für die 2,50 Euro
mehr ist rechtlich.
Ja, bei den meisten
gibt es ja nicht mal so viel mehr.
Ne, also ehrlich, da hätte ich keinen Bock. Und was noch
schlimmer ist als Projektleitung, finde
ich, ist so verantwortungsmäßig,
ist so Einsteiger-Level-Management,
so Teamleitung oder sowas.
Nicht, dass ich den Job
schlimm an sich finde, ja, wenn
das jemand macht, aber ich kann es nicht verstehen,
wenn das jemand macht, freiwillig, weil
du kriegst den Anschiss von deinen Leuten,
die sind permanent am Meckern,
und du kriegst den Anschiss von deinem Chef,
wenn irgendwas nicht funktioniert. Du bist also im Prinzip
an der Position, wo
du, wenn du es nicht wirklich
von Anfang an
da Durchblick hast,
eigentlich dazu prädestiniert bist, aufgerieben zu werden zwischen deinen Leuten und deinen Chefs.
So als Teamleitung.
Deswegen hätte ich überhaupt keinen Bock auf diese Position.
Du musst dir permanent Gemegge anhören von deinen Leuten aus den Teams und von denen oben drüber.
dass wir auch die deswegen zu gut ab vor jedem der das macht ja und noch mehr vor denen die das
auch noch gut machen aber ich hätte wirklich gar keinen bock drauf auf so eine position
die notwendigen kompetenzen dafür besitzt und ich bin froh dass es leute gibt muss ich auch
noch mal sagen ja als ich bin froh dass mein chef an der position ist wo er ist und das macht was
er macht. Ich würde es nicht machen wollen. Man wird ins kalte Wasser geworfen, aber man kann
schwimmen. Wir sind jetzt in der Maschinenhalle hier vom V0V IPT, wo wir die Maschinen haben,
an denen wir auch forschen. Da man sich unter künstlicher Intelligenz in der Produktion
manchmal nur schwer was vorstellen kann. Beste Notebook hier. Die richtig, das ist schon ein
Lenovo Notebook. Die alten
IBM Notebooks mit
noch Metallscharnieren
am Display.
So ein IBM
Thinkpad. Was ist denn da der Klassiker?
Ne, hießen die X? X hießen
die doch. X41
und sowas, ne?
Genau!
So ein Klotz!
Das waren doch ordentliche
Notebooks.
Opa Max spricht.
Nee, ist das X41?
T hießen die.
T.
Ja, so richtig
dick. Hier sieht man es glaube ich ganz gut.
Guckt mal, Leute.
Noch so richtig dick mit
Metallscharniere
am Notebook.
Und diesem komischen Knubbel.
das hat man, das ist so ein Ding,
das hat IBM gerne gemacht, ich weiß nicht, ob die das
heute noch machen, damit konnte man die Maus,
das war so ein Joystick für die Maus quasi, dieser Knubbel.
Den haben die noch.
Die hat echte, echte Metallscharniere
noch. Also die Dinger waren nahezu
unkaputtbar.
Wir hatten bis zum Schluss auf der alten Arbeit,
weiß ich noch, im Schrank hatten wir
auch irgendwie so ein Ding liegen,
mit Ubuntu
ähm, was war das?
804.
Xubuntu
Von 2008
war da drauf.
Ging immer noch.
So, aber
erstmal, nein, nein, nein, falsches Video.
Fertig gucken.
Was ich mir vorstellen kann,
haben wir in einem Projekt einen Demonstrator gebaut, der das Ganze veranschaulicht.
Aber im Grunde, was halt passiert, wir haben halt hier vorne die Kamera, die Kamera und das Licht.
Und die ist an einem Raspberry Pi angeschlossen und schickt dann das Bild an eine VM in der Fraunhofer Edge Cloud.
In der was?
In der Fra... Ach, jetzt hab ich's verstanden.
In der Fraunhofer Edge... Was ist denn die?
Fraunhofer Edge Cloud.
Okay, das gibt's anscheinend. Alles klar.
Da wird auch die Vorhersage gemacht.
Edge Cloud. Das klingt so ein bisschen wie
nach, ähm...
Irgendwelches IoT-Kram, oder?
Das heißt, da habt ihr auch das Modell.
Genau, das Modell liegt quasi in der Cloud auf der virtuellen Maschine.
Ziel des Termins jetzt ist es, zu besprechen, wie wir mit dem Demonstrator weiter machen.
So IoT-mäßig.
Wir sind schon auf Messen.
Meinung zu Lidl Cloud, kein Nix zu sagen.
Wir wollen aber noch mehr Leute auf uns aufmerksam machen,
um noch einen besseren Wow-Effekt bei den Leuten auf Messen oder bei Firmenbesuchen hier zu erzielen.
Wir gucken gleich mal Lidl Cloud, was da noch vor allem kostet.
Hier oben sehen wir, dass die Schweißnaht fehlte.
und hier unten sehen wir zum Beispiel, dass die...
Hey, Moment, das muss ich jetzt nochmal angucken. Ich habe es nicht gecheckt.
Moin, Alex.
Was wir hier haben, ist ein Beispielprodukt.
Hier oben sehen wir, dass die Schweißnaht fehlte
und hier unten sehen wir zum Beispiel...
Ich sehe da nichts. Seht ihr da was?
...beispiel, dass die Schweißnaht unvollständig ist.
Ich sehe da nichts.
Ah, doch! Hier! Hier oben ist nichts.
Hier oben ist kein Klingel.
Hier ist der Klingel nicht komplett.
So muss der Klingel drumherum sein.
Dafür braucht man KI.
Okay.
Das Ziel ist es jetzt, über eine visuelle Inspektion automatisiert zu erkennen, ob hier...
Ah, die KI soll das erkennen.
Okay, das ist natürlich ein sehr sinnliches Anwendungsfeld für KI.
...Effekte vorliegen.
Dafür ist das echt gut.
Wenn ein Defekt erkannt hat, dann leuchtet der ganze Aufbau...
Und das macht auch Sinn.
Wenigstens nicht irgendein sinnloses Buzzword-Zeug, sondern was, was wirklich handfest auch am Ende was bringt.
Das finde ich schon mal gut.
Wenn kein Defekt erkannt ist, dann sehen wir quasi ein grünes Licht.
Den Demonstrator wollen wir aktuell noch etwas weiterentwickeln, um den Wow-Faktor zu erhöhen.
Das heißt, wie kriegen wir, wenn du davor stehst, diesen Demonstrator siehst,
wie kriegen wir für Dummies erklärt,
Für Dummies und zeigt auf ihn, also für dich,
dass das nur ein Beispiel ist von dem, was wir machen,
von zigtausenden, die wir anwenden.
Und sonst konkurrierst du mit irgendwelchen Startups.
Tom war auf der Vision-Messe.
Du hast halt tausende Startups,
die halt nur industrielle Bildverarbeitung machen.
Aber mit denen wollen wir ja gar nicht konkurrieren.
Sonst sieht es nur so aus,
als ob wir den Demonstrator verkaufen würden.
Wollen wir ja gar nicht.
Ja, wir wollen die Kompetenz dahinter verkaufen.
Richtig.
Wir planen gegebenenfalls weitere Produkte.
Ah, die Kompetenz dahinter.
Das heißt im Endeffekt,
sie wollen geconsulted werden oder wie oder was oder wo.
Dann Basilikum beispielsweise drunter legen könnte.
Um trainieren von irgendwelchen Models.
Welcher Basilikum ist so gut.
Also quasi, Sie wollen Know-How verkaufen im Trainieren von Models sozusagen.
Und welcher nicht gut ist.
Ja, ist schon so ein bisschen wie so ein Baby.
Oder Sie verkaufen dann quasi die fertig trainierten Sachen über Ihre Cloud mit Abo.
Aber ich bin ganz froh, dass auch jetzt andere Leute noch mal ihren so frischen Wind reinbringen können.
Ihre eigenen Ideen.
Presentation.
Mein Arbeitsvertrag ist auf fünf Jahre befristet.
Das deckt sich auch mit der Dauer der Promotion.
Die Promotion ist bei uns in Anführungsstrichen berufsbegleitend.
Das heißt, wir haben einen ganz normalen Arbeitsvertrag.
Und die Promotion ist ein Vorhaben, was man dann teilweise in seiner Freizeit vorantreiben muss.
Ich habe Hunger. Nicht unbedingt da drauf, aber ich habe echt Hunger.
Gerade weil ich gestern wieder so aktiv war. Wie gesagt, sieben Kilometer gerannt, 52 Kilometer Fahrrad gefahren.
Ich habe brutalst Hunger.
Nudeln mit Lachs, nein es gibt keine Nudeln mit Lachs
Wenn es Nudeln mit Lachs geben würde
Hätte es gestern Nudeln mit Lachs gegeben
Und das gab es nicht
Gestern gab es irgendwelche Reste
Es gab noch ein halbes Schnitzel
Ein bisschen übrig geblieben mit Kartoffeln
Und nachdem das nicht gereicht hat
Habe ich mir einfach noch drei Waffeln
In Toaster gesteckt
und, ne stimmt nicht, vier Waffeln in Toaster
gesteckt
und Nutella drauf geschmiert.
Exquisite
gesund.
In den Industrieprojekten ist schon Druck da.
Also da wird schon auch
alles erwartet.
Bist du jetzt wieder regelmäßig live?
Ich versuche mal wieder ein bisschen öfters da zu sein.
Ja, das ist der Plan. Ich habe ja die meisten
Sachen, die mir Sorgen bereitet
haben, gelöst.
Schon Druck da.
Also da wird schon
auch alles erwartet. Das ist auch so ein bisschen das Problem, was manchmal Fraunhofer hat, dass wir
so als Jugend forscht wahrgenommen werden und müssen dann aber auch zeigen, dass wir industrienah
arbeiten können und eben auch teilweise mit Beratungen konkurrieren. In dem konkreten Fall
geht es um fein gegossene Turbinen-Schau. Das sah ein bisschen wie der Bauer aus im Hintergrund,
eine oder? Ich meine, da ist das nicht, aber da sahen die auf den ersten Blick...
Oder? So von der Frisur?
Ich hab's erst gedacht, wo sind sie da gelandet?
Das heißt, wenn man sich so ein Triebwerk von einem Flugzeug vorstellt, da guckt man vorne quasi
auf die Turbinen-Schaufeln drauf und die werden über ein Feingießverfahren hergestellt.
Aha.
Das Problem in dem konkreten Fall ist, dass es nicht möglich ist, die Produkte entlang ihrer
verschiedenen Schritte der Fertigung zu tracken. Das heißt, man weiß nicht, welches Produkt an
welcher Stelle zu welchem Zeitpunkt war. Das ist was für Vibe-Coder. Da werden wir uns eben anschauen,
wie man sicherstellen kann, dass man einen Überblick hat und genau weiß, welches Produkt
wann an welcher Maschine war. Wenn wir jetzt eine richtige Turbinen-Schaufel herstellen würden und
die in ein Passagierflugzeug eingesetzt wird, herrschen sehr, sehr strenge Sicherheitsvorschriften.
Und das müssen wir auch dementsprechend kontrollieren, weil es eben bei einem richtigen Beurteilung um Menschenleben ginge.
Wir nehmen zunächst einmal den Prozess überhaupt auf und es bildet die Basis für alle unsere Analysen danach.
Ich lese dir mal Wikipedia vor.
Vibe-Coding ist eine Programmiertechnik, welche sich ganz auf künstliche Intelligenz zum Generieren des Quellcodes verlässt
und somit Programmierung auch für Unerfahrene zugänglich macht.
Du sagst eigentlich nur noch, was du haben willst und bloß mit den Vibes.
Vibeprompting ist der neue Trend. Aha, okay.
Ohne eine Rückverfolgbarkeit der Daten kann man auch keine Datenanalyse machen,
weil man eben nicht weiß, die Daten, die man aufnimmt, wie man die Daten miteinander verknüpft.
Wie lang dauert das Ganze, quasi das Starten?
Ein, zwei Minuten.
Ja, du hast gesagt zwei, drei.
So was in dem Rahmen.
Das war ein super Termin.
Superspannend, das schon mal in echt dann auch zu sehen,
wie die Bauteile hergestellt werden, wie die vermessen werden.
Jetzt geht's auf einmal zurück ins Büro,
noch ein paar letzte Mails beantworten, noch ein bisschen was für morgen vorbereiten.
Geht auch klar.
Monatlich verdiene ich 5.390 Euro brutto und davon bleiben mir 3.330 Euro netto.
Von den 3.330 Euro geht dann noch die Zusatzversorgung, nämlich die betriebliche Altersvorsorge weg
und damit bleiben mir 3.236 Euro.
Es gibt eine Jahressonderzahlung und dazu noch eine individuelle Leistungsprämie und
eine Erfolgsbeteiligung.
Ah ja, Stomps.
Ich habe jetzt nicht richtig mitgerechnet, aber klang doch erstmal ganz brauchbar, oder?
Irgendwas um 80k oder so habe ich da jetzt gerade.
So über den Daumen, oder?
Es ist ein super Gehalt, gerade wenn man frisch aus dem Studium kommt und eben noch geringe Ausgaben hat.
Und deshalb bin ich mit meinem Gehalt eigentlich sehr zufrieden.
Ja da kommt ja noch ein Bonus und so drauf.
Deswegen habe ich gerade irgendwas um 80k…
Ich hole jetzt noch ein Paket vom Paketshop ab, der es gleich zumacht…
Aber wir sehen es ja am Ende nochmal…
Wir haben neue Filter für den Katzenboden…
Oh nein…
Toss…
Social Leute, die gehen dann abends noch in die Bar und sitzen dann um 19 Uhr in der Bar und trinken dann noch irgendwas und irgendwelche Hipster-Sachen.
Um 19 Uhr, wisst ihr, was ich um 19 Uhr mache? Um 19 Uhr mache ich das gleiche wie die 12 Stunden davor. Ich sitze daheim am Computer.
Eventuell stream so ich oder mache irgendwelchen MMO-Kreisel-Crime.
Eventuell, eventuell, nee, 19 Uhr bin ich eigentlich mit Sport schon durch.
Okay, 65k, ja gut, da kommt aber noch
Bonus irgendwie drauf
Okay, 80 habe ich mich verrechnet
Ja, das muss er jetzt sagen
Aber das, ich meine, eins muss man ihm
jetzt manchmal zugute halten, im Vergleich zu vielen
anderen dieser Beiträge
Er scheint ja am Tag auch wirklich was
gearbeitet zu haben also mein lieblings negativ beispiel von diesen beiträgen ist die die die
eine projektmanagerin gewesen die den ganzen tag nur irgendwelche excel dinger befüllt hat
das hat hd arbeit verkauft hat
ich wollte euch mal einen tweet zeigen den muss ja mal raus und wie nennt man das jetzt
eigentlich das ist ja kein tweet mehr ein 1 1 oder so muss ja mal kurz auf dem handy gucken
...
nicht so richtig mehr besuchen sagt halt mal richtig letztes hat mir
eine auf der post heißen jetzt okay
letztes hat einer aus meiner timeline auf diesen post geantwortet ich kenne
den account nicht aber ich habe dann auch darauf geantworten zwar hat hat er
hier keine ahnung was er sonst so postet weiß nicht wie ging es mir ging es um
um die Meldung, ja.
Ernst, ernst gemeinte Warnung.
Ermutigt eure Kinder, nicht
mehr Programmierer zu werden. Noch bevor
Ausbildung und Studium abgeschlossen ist, wird
nicht mehr annähernd genug Jobs dafür geben.
Der AI Meltdown wird hier am
schnellst und heftigst werden und er beginnt bereits.
Okay, Chat. Ich würde gerne eure Meinung dazu wissen,
was ihr dazu denkt.
Der klassische Ragebait,
meinst du wirklich, es ist
absichtlich so geschrieben, dass die Leute darauf anspringen?
Weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, der meint das wirklich.
Weil hier, da steht irgendwas von
CEO und sonst was. Das ist natürlich
der Traum eines
CEOs, dass er in Zukunft keine
Programmierer mehr suchen muss.
Also ich glaube schon, dass er das denkt.
So die Jobentwicklung
der letzten Jahre hat es nicht unbedingt gezeigt.
Auch wenn er
bereits begonnen hat.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass
das der Fall sein wird.
Ja, auf Twitter hast du so die Spezialleute, die da...
Die müssen das schon schreiben, weil die Leute es von ihnen erwarten, ja, aber...
Ist halt was dran? Denkst du wirklich?
Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube nicht, dass ich...
Ja, okay, ich meine, deswegen interessiert es mich, was ihr dazu denkt.
Also ich denke nicht, dass sich das in nächster Zeit negativ auf den Jobmarkt auswirken wird für Programmierer.
Ich denke auch eher, dass es noch der Bedarf in Zukunft weiter steigen wird.
Weil sind wir mal ehrlich, es gab immer mal schon wieder, fangen wir mal so an, es gab immer mal schon wieder irgendwelche Trends,
so nach dem Motto, bald kann der Chef selbst bestimmen, wie eine App entsteht, ohne dass er Programmierer dafür braucht.
Zwischenzeitlich gab es mal irgendwelche Low-Code-Plattformen, da kann sich die Marketingabteilung jetzt selbst ihre App zusammen klickern und so.
Oder früher, wie hat da einer geschrieben in den Kommentaren?
Lotus Notes wollte auch schon mal den Programmierer ersetzen.
Alter, Lotus Notes.
Ja.
Das hat aber auch nicht dazu beigebracht, also generell hat Low-Code und dieses Gezeug auch nicht dazu beigetragen,
dass du weniger Programmierer brauchst.
Weil, wisst ihr, ihr kommt nicht drauf, aber wisst ihr, wer die Low-Code-Plattform entwickelt bzw. anpasst?
Sind tatsächlich Programmierer.
Wäre dir das gedacht?
Und es wird ja nicht Low-Code in Low-Code programmiert.
Also, ich glaube nicht, dass das der Fall sein wird.
Ich stütze das mal auf zwei Sachen.
Das erste ist, ich verfolge das seit Jahren schon und ich versuche auch seit Jahren schon immer mal wieder so ein bisschen schwierigere Probleme, ey, lass doch mal gucken, was die AI dazu sagt.
Regelmäßig probiere ich das immer mal wieder aus und es dauert meistens keine 5 Minuten, bis ich enttäuscht von dem bin, was ChatGPT oder sonst was ausspuckt.
Und wir reden jetzt mal absichtlich von Dingern, die nicht generieren mir eine Web-App mit den und den Seiten bla bla bla. Also jetzt keine shiny fake Demo-Webseiten, Web-Apps erstellen. Das kann AI wunderbar, da sage ich nichts dagegen.
vielleicht ist das auch erste april weil sie nicht kann auch sein vielleicht mal vielleicht
meint das auch wirklich so ja aber ich habe das die letzten drei jahre immer wieder und das letzte
ist noch gar nicht lange her ausprobiert und ich bin bei komplizierten sachen immer sehr schnell
enttäuscht,
was
AI ausspuckt.
Letztens habe ich ChatGPT gefragt,
wie man per
CAP eine KVM
VM erstellt.
Per Low-Level CAP. Ohne LibWirt.
Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht,
ich habe ja mal was gebaut
auf GitHub, nämlich den VM-Champ,
den wir irgendwann vielleicht auch mal weitermachen
sollten.
Der benutzt LibWirt.
Und ich wollte mal gucken, wie das geht mit KVM direkt
ohne Lib wird.
Und Leute, was
ChatGPT da ausgespuckt hat.
Vielleicht können wir es ja sogar
nachstellen.
Vielleicht können wir es ja sogar nachstellen.
Es ist immer ein bisschen random, was ChatGPT
ausspuckt. Okay.
Wir fragen ChatGPT mal.
Ich möchte
per LowLevel
CAP eine KVM
unter Linux
erstellen. Wie geht
das?
Es geht erstmal gar nichts.
Es stinkt.
Broken.
Ich hab's kaputt gemacht.
Okay, Refreshen.
Oh, oh, Network Error.
Okay.
Um eine KV-Modellösung mit einer C-Low-Level-Arme
müssen Sie die KV-Modellösung
in Ihrem Kern nutzen.
Okay, okay, okay.
What the...
Das ist neu.
Das letzte Mal hat es was anderes...
Ich kann mir nicht...
Das wird so wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
AIStudioGoogle.com, sollen wir mal gucken.
Also das letzte Mal, okay, das ist wieder was anderes.
Das kann ich jetzt nicht einschätzen, wie viel Wahrheitsgehalt da jetzt dran ist.
Zumindest habe ich so meine Zweifel, dass das funktioniert.
So, aber da haben wir jetzt schon wieder das nächste Problem bei AI Code Generation.
Wollen wir das mal gucken. Wir fragen hier.
Du musst das ja immer noch verstehen.
Und das schmeißt dir irgendwelche unvollständigen Brocken hin und du musst dann da was rausbauen.
Nein, das glaube ich nicht.
Das glaube ich einfach nicht, dass das so weit kommen wird.
Weil ich probiere das seit drei Jahren immer wieder aus und ich bin mega schnell enttäuscht, weil es sich die größten Crap zusammen halluziniert.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass sich eventuell die Arbeit ein bisschen ändern wird.
Ja, es macht jetzt ja auch schon Sinn zu sagen, hier guck mal, ich habe das und das programmiert, gibt es da irgendwelche Fehler drin, siehst du da im Programmablauf irgendwelche Probleme, könnte man das noch etwas optimierter gestalten oder so.
Dafür ist das alles gut.
Aber schon bei einfachen Sachen wie beispielsweise Kubernetes-Jammels generieren,
halluziniert sich Chat-GPT teilweise richtig krasses Zeug zusammen.
Und am Ende hast du das Problem, es muss immer noch einer verstehen, was passiert.
Und überlegt euch mal, was es für ein Aufwand ist,
das KI-generierte Stückwerk wieder auseinander zu bröseln,
um da drin vielleicht was zu ändern.
ganz ehrlich ich sehe es nicht ich verstehe dass man vielleicht ein
bisschen anders arbeiten wird in zukunft eventuell aber dass das wirklich
programmierer ersetzt sehe ich einfach nicht
letztens gab es erst noch die news chat gpt wird immer dümmer kann man das kann
man das kostenlos treiben
Also das glaube ich nicht, dass das passieren wird.
Und wisst ihr was auch die Pest ist?
KI generierte Blogartikel
Kennt ihr diese ganzen tausend generierten Blogartikel
Zu irgendwelchen Themen
Wo du direkt merkst
Irgendeiner ist auf ChatGPT gegangen
Hat gesagt ich hätte jetzt gern ein
Was weiß ich
ein blog artikel zum thema message broker in dotnet und dann generiert das
dir 50 seiten von belanglosesten scheiß
ja es kann man machen also ich sehe nicht dass das irgendwie
programmierer überflüssig machen würde sie aus finden das natürlich toll weil
die kriegen keine neuen programmierer und schon gar keine gescheiten neuen
programmierer die würden gerne sagen ja das wird alles durch abgelöst ich sehe das nicht ja es
mag sich ein bisschen ändern wie man arbeiten wird wobei auch sich das er so im fluss entwickeln wird
und nicht heute ist alles anders aber dass man weniger bock ich sehe es nicht man könnte schon
eher sagen man braucht weniger admins dadurch dass mehr sachen in der cloud läuft und selbst
da kann man sich darüber streiten wie das so wirklich ob das wirklich weniger sind und auch
ein ding anderes beispiel wo es vor jahren noch erzählt wurde ja wenn man in die cloud geht
wahnsinnig kosteneinsparung potenzial und was meint ihr wie viele der leute die gesagt haben
wir packen jetzt alles in die cloud am ende wirklich kosten gespart haben da war man auch
felsenfest davon überzeugt dass wir zu sein weil einem dass die marketing leute von den cloud
anbietern schön gerechnet haben
da hat sich der kosten ja wenn die berater haben nicht die berater haben
fette verdient ja glaubt ist doch immer teurer man kann das so pauschal nicht
sagen du kannst in der regel kann man nur sagen also eine sache die immer
falsch ist, ist eigentlich zu sagen,
dass eine Sache immer falsch oder richtig ist.
Widerspruch in sich,
ja, aber
man könnte sagen, in der Regel
wird Cloud nicht billiger sein.
Hat andere Vorteile.
Cloud kann aber
günstiger sein. Durchaus.
Also, wenn die
Bedingungen zusammenkommen.
Wenn man sich
irgendwo eingemietet hat, Miete
bezahlen muss, dort dann auch viele
Hardware hat, die nicht richtig ausgelastet ist,
Ähm, das kann günstiger sein, gerade wenn du eine stark, ähm, wie nennt man das, also, wenn du so starke Fluktuationen unterworfen bist, da kann das durchaus günstiger sein in der Cloud, wenn du dich architekturmäßig so aufstellst, dass deine Infrastruktur gut skalierbar ist.
Also dass du sagst, hey, an einem Tag haben wir, ist übertrieben gesagt, ja, an einem Tag haben wir nur, an einem Tag haben wir null User, wir können quasi so weit runter skalieren wie möglich, am besten eigentlich nur noch die Management Sachen oben lassen, von den ganzen Workern aus und sonst was alles runterfahren und am anderen Tag hat uns PewDiePie in einem Stream gezeigt und wir haben jetzt 150.000 Requests pro Sekunde und dann können wir das Ganze hochskalieren.
dann kann sich das rechnen
also wirklich auch
ordentlich rechnen
so Sachen in der Cloud zu betreiben
es ist nicht so, dass man sowas nicht selbst bauen kann
aber in der Regel brauchst du ein Rechenzentrum
du brauchst die Hardware, irgendwie muss die ja sein
und das können Cloud-Anbieter auch nur machen
weil sich die Hardware unten drunter eben geteilt wird
von mehreren Leuten
dann kann sich das rechnen
in der Regel würde ich sagen
fährst du mit der Cloud
egal ob es jetzt
AWS, Azure oder GCP ist, fährst du nicht unbedingt günstiger.
Zumal die Cloud-Hersteller noch so eine kleine negative Angewohnheit haben.
Die bauen immer gerne Abhängigkeiten zu sich selbst ein.
Also so kleine Dinge, die dann nur bei ihnen gehen.
Oder aber sie fangen auf einmal an, Geld zu verlangen für Sachen, die bisher kostenlos waren.
Zum Beispiel, Google hat sich jetzt überlegt, kostet es 1,50 Euro.
Ja, klar.
Google hat sich jetzt überlegt,
dass
ab April
kostet jede
Alerting-Rule
1,50 Euro pro Monat.
Warum?
Weil es geht.
ihr müsst euch also was damit gemeint ist zum beispiel du hast eine alert regel wenn die vm
länger als fünf minuten über 80 prozent cpu last braucht dann schickt mir eine mail das ist damit
So eine Alert-Regel ist damit gemeint.
Ist aktuell kostenlos, kostet dann 1,50 Euro.
Ab April 2026.
Hat sich Google einfach überlegt, können wir jetzt machen.
Gutes Beispiel ist doch jetzt die Hannover Messe.
Du bist ein Hersteller auf der Messe, dann 20 Jahre.
Ja, genau. Für sowas ist das sinnvoll.
Wobei man da aber halt sagen muss,
für sowas musst du nicht unbedingt zu einem Cloud-Anbieter gehen
und musst es auch nicht super krass skalierbar machen.
Wenn du einfach nur drei Wochen das Jahr eine Webseite anzeigen willst,
da kannst du dir auch irgendwo eine VM mieten, das darauf schmeißen und danach wieder löschen.
Aber für sowas ist das natürlich sinnvoll.
Aber in der Regel würde ich sagen, fährst du mit der Cloud nicht wirklich günstiger,
da auch immer sehr viele Sachen dran hängen, was extra kostet.
Man denkt sich so, ja gut, eine VM kann man alles schön skalieren
oder vielleicht sogar ein Managed Kubernetes Cluster, kann man alles schön skalieren
und rechnet sich dann, mag vielleicht sein, dass sich das in diesem Fall rechnet,
aber da hängt ja immer noch Zeug dran.
Alert-Regeln hängen hinten dran, Metriken, die gesammelt werden müssen,
Snapshots von Festplatten, Cloud-Shell-Storage,
da kommt immer ganz viel Gedöns drumherum.
Irgendwelche Ingress-Traffic, irgendwie Zwischentraffic, der vielleicht da noch was kostet.
Eventuell braucht man da nochmal eine SSD mit einer IOPS-Requirement
und sowas wurde die probleme hast überhaupt nicht wenn du den server hast
mit der ssd drin das kommt einiges zusammen
Meinst du die haben schon mal für 2026 einen April Scherz gemacht?
Bei Google.
Achso stimmt wir wollten ja gucken.
Stack it Lidl.
Cloud
Ne, gucken wir mal, was da kostet
Man findet das noch nicht mal, ist das das hier?
Okay
Ein unabhängiges Europa, digital
führen, stack it, die deutsche Cloud
für Unternehmen, okay, Preise
Gucken wir mal
Preise, IAS
Pass, stack it, confidential
oder co-location
Also, gucken wir mal hier
Compute Engine, Secure Manager, okay.
Compute Engine und...
Ist Runtime und Kubernetes managed?
Die Webseite finde ich grausam, ehrlich gesagt.
Also das...
Wie nennt man das?
Das Design der Webseite finde ich grausam.
Es ist einheitlich, es ist absichtlich so gedacht.
Es ist nicht schlecht, dass man sagen könnte,
es hat sich keiner Gedanken gemacht, aber ich finde es schlimm.
Okay, was kostet es denn?
Die kostengünstige Option.
Intel Gen 1 und Intel Gen 2.
Kostet?
Verfügbarkeit.
Single.
Metro.
Intel.
Komm.
AMD ist billiger.
Nee.
AMD ist teurer.
Intel Managed Service.
Ja.
Nein.
Hä?
Monatlich.
alter 100 euro für eine vier kern vm mit 8 g gramm das ist ja schon ordentlich bei
Google ist da nicht billiger.
Gucken wir mal, was es bei AMD kostet.
Boah, das ist aber...
Das ist schon ordentlich.
Google bekleckert sich auch nicht mit Preisen,
was Compute Instances angeht.
Gucken wir mal den Armpreis.
Guck mal.
Also, ganz ehrlich, wenn man einfach nur eine 4M will, muss ich ehrlich sagen, da schlägt nichts.
Es muss nicht unbedingt Hetzner sein.
Aber es gibt ja noch ein paar mehr günstige Cloud-Anbieter.
Da schlägt nichts, einfach sich so ein Shared-CPU-Ding zu kaufen.
Die haben ihre...
Haben die keine...
Drei Kern, genau.
Das ist für mich meine Lieblings-VM hier.
3 CPU-Kerne, 4 GB RAM.
Das ist meine Lieblings-VM-Größe bei Hetzner.
Das ist als Preis-Leistung für mich das Beste.
3 CPUs, 4 GB RAM, 80 GB SSD und relativ günstig weiteren SSDs.
Also guck mal, hier kriegst du das Gleiche für 16 Euro im Monat.
So, ARM haben die ja auch, glaube ich.
ist noch mal ein bisschen günstiger dedicated selbst dedicated cpu ist eine
ganze ecke günstiger als die computerinstanz sind sind ja richtig
teuer so kommt man mal was die man also eins muss man aber jetzt an der stelle
auch noch mal dazu sagen es ist ein bisschen unfair jetzt reine
hetzler vm preise mit einer kompletten cloud mit komplett umfassenden cloud
anbieter zu vergleichen die können ja auch viel mehr aber wenn man sich jetzt
wirklich nur auf diese eine sache guckt ich brauche eine vm die ich laufen
lassen kann irgendwo anders nicht bei mir daheim
dann fährst du mit mit hetzner oder was ist sonst was was ist denn da was ist
noch ähnlich günstig wie hetzler hostinger macht immer werbung aktuell in
allen möglichen videos habe ich mir noch nie angeguckt net cup oder so o v h
genau ja dann ist das sinnig wenn man natürlich jetzt die ganzen anderen
services braucht ja zum beispiel in dem manager postgres irgendwelches messaging
automatisierte backup geschichten in ordentlichen terraform provider wobei
den gibt es für hetzen auch eine manager kubernetes cluster und solche
geschichten dann ist natürlich eine komplett umfassende cloud umgebung wie
es bei google und bei escher bei aws gibt besser dann ist aber vm wer dann
das nicht vor allem dann ist vm irgend so nebenprodukt das ist mal gucken was
jeder manager cluster kostet ist das denn überhaupt ein kuba netz über ja es
ist kuba netz engine bei lidl stündlich monatlich
Okay, das muss man sich irgendwie selbst ausrechnen.
Das macht tatsächlich ganz gut.
Bei Google gibt es so einen Price Calculator.
Bei Strato.
Bei Strato kannst du ja auch eine VM holen.
Ich habe tatsächlich bei Strato eine VM.
Da gab es mal eine.
Habe ich seit Jahren schon.
Da gab es mal ein Angebot.
angebot 1 euro für eine vm mit public ipv4 adresse für immer 1 euro im monat
für immer und das habe ich seit vor ein paar jahren abgeschlossen und seitdem
habe ich die allein schon für die public ipv4 adresse werde ich die für immer
behalten
ja hier kannst du bei google kannst du irgendwelche sachen hinzufügen
der compute engine wir wollen das ist ein ganzer monat
ja mal ein zwei aber hier 16 in den pop ist es okay
ssd persistent disk google ist da auch nicht wirklich also bm preise sind da
nicht sind da nicht ohne ist sie auch hoch verfügbar die ist nur so hoch
verfügbar wie der google standort hoch verfügbar ist du kannst von ausgehen
dass in google stand quasi ein google rechenzentrum an sich eine recht gute
verfügbarkeit aufweisen wird aber wenn sagen wir du hast eine vm in europe west
3 c stehen und das ist das single einzelne vm dann ist die auch nur in
europe west 3c da musst du dich selbst drum kümmern also wenn du den service darauf laufen
hast und willst dass der auch bei einem ausfall von europe west 3c nahtlos weiterläuft musste
sich selbst drum kümmern es gibt die möglichkeit beispielsweise bei es kann zu sagen ich hätte
gerne eine wie heißt das dort nochmal region oder geo red und nicht wie heißt das bei elsa
Bei Azure kannst du das beispielsweise direkt anhaken, dass du sagst, ich will eine VM, die country-redundant ist und so.
Das geht kostenlos aber extra.
Ansonsten, wenn du dir einfach eine Thing, das kannst du ja immer auswählen.
Du kannst bei Google, kannst du ja auch sagen, was du als Location haben willst.
Willst du eine, wie heißt das bei Google, eine Region oder eine, weiß ich gerade gar nicht, Location?
Ja genau
Du kannst sagen
Du willst eine Region oder eine Zone haben
Als Location kannst du angeben
Bei Google
Und
Zonen ist dann sowas wie
Europe West 3C
Das ist Frankfurt
Oder du kannst auch sagen Europe West 3
Dann ist das was
Über diese
Region redundantes
Kostet aber immer extra
Wenn du einfach nur noch VM in einer Zone anlegst, dann ist die weg, wenn die Zone weg ist und das kommt ab und zu mal tatsächlich vor. Also wenn du dir zum Beispiel einen Managed Kubernetes Cluster holst bei Google, dann musst du anhaken beim Erstellen des Clusters, dass du damit einverstanden bist, dass du Google mindestens, ich bin mir nicht sicher was es ist, zwei Stunden im Monat oder so,
Wartungsarbeiten
zugestehst.
Also wo die den Cluster upgraden können
und sowas. In der Regel machen die das
aber Rolling-Upgrade
mäßig. Also da ist dann nicht der ganze
Cluster weg.
Ja. So, was
haben wir denn sonst noch hier Schönes?
South Korea
is over. Das klingt so deprimierend
irgendwie.
ok wir gucken uns jetzt mal an realistic week in the life of a software engineer
amazon oder amazon ist die coolen leute sagen
warum wir uns das mal an was der so treibt
Oh no
Wieso, ist das schlimm?
Oh, was ein Sound
Also bei uns ist es so, wir haben auch so
Ich hab euch ja im Stream schon mal gezeigt
Wir haben auch so eine Notification App
Die
Das hat einfach die normalen Klingeltonen
Dann
Das ist ja abartig.
Wow, mein Fan hat immer das 1 in der URL.
Das ist einfach.
Guck mal, da gibt es sogar ein Video zu, wo ich das erkläre.
Das Problem ist oftmals, ich weiß nicht wie das bei euch ist, für Leute, die auch in dieser Richtung arbeiten, ich bin ja immer relativ früh auf der Arbeit da. Ich bin einer, würde ich sagen, ich bin eigentlich einer der ersten meistens, die sich einloggt.
Und da kriegst du prozentual gesehen die meisten Dinge ab, weil den Leuten morgens halt auffällt,
wenn was nicht funktioniert.
Und das Problem ist, dass wir glaube ich 13 Services bei uns im Team haben.
Wirklich auskennen tue ich mich mit drei bis vier davon.
Und bei den anderen Services kann ich immer nur Feuer löschen.
So nach dem Motto, Festplatte ist voll, ich zipp mal ein paar Loks.
Oder ich starte mal neu und hoffe, das wird schon funktionieren.
Oder ich gucke mal in der History, in der Hoffnung, dass irgendjemand, der das letzte Mal drin war, auch schon sowas ähnliches gefixt hat.
Also es ist immer kein gutes Gefühl, morgens da zu sitzen und irgendjemand meldet sich von einem Service, wo du keine Ahnung von hast.
Ja.
Aber, also, man würde es gar nicht glauben, wie viel auch im professionellen Business-Enterprise-Umfeld Neustart das Problem behebt.
Also wir haben eine Stunde, also wenn man
bei uns Bereitschaft hat, das ist nicht
standardmäßig, wir haben eine Stunde
Zeit ready
zu sein, also
ich finde das auch schon immer stressig
wenn ich hier gerade mal eine Runde
am Main lang laufe und ich weiß
okay, ich bin potenziell immer innerhalb von einer Stunde wieder daheim.
Aber wenn du dann gerade so in der Mitte der Runde bist
und es dauert eine halbe Stunde, bis du wieder daheim bist,
du kriegst einen Anruf.
Die machen natürlich übelst Hektik am Telefon immer,
obwohl du eigentlich eine Stunde Zeit hast, an den Rechner zu kommen.
Also du gehst dann dran und sagst,
ja, was ist denn?
Und dann sagen die,
ja, erklär mal, ich bin gerade unterwegs,
ich brauche eine halbe Stunde, bis ich daheim bin.
Oh, was machen wir denn jetzt?
Da schieben die natürlich schon Panik.
Aber ich meine, man versucht natürlich schneller wieder da zu sein.
Also es ist schon sehr stressvoll.
Und wenn man das eine ganze Woche hat, stelle ich mir heftig vor.
Eine Stunde Reaktionszeit, ja.
Du hattest vier Stunden Reaktionszeit im Krankenhaus.
Okay, nee, bei uns ist es eine Stunde.
Aber man muss das ja auch verstehen.
Es ist, Chad, es ist doch logisch, dass man im Krankenhaus vier Stunden Reaktionszeit hat und wir eine Stunde.
Im Krankenhaus hängen nur Menschenleben dran.
Bei uns hängt Geld dran.
ist doch logisch was da schneller bereitschaft sein muss oder ist das eine
zusatzvereinbarung mit extra geld oder ist das extra geld
extra geld
Und teilweise echt nicht zu knapp.
Also bei uns gibt es um fast, fast, es ist nicht ganz,
wenn du bei uns ein Wochenende Rufbereitschaft hast,
das Rufbereitschaft bei uns Wochenende heißt,
von Freitag Ende der Arbeit bis Montag Beginn der Arbeit,
also 48, boah, keine Ahnung, was da noch dazu ist,
ich sag mal 60 Stunden oder so, bisschen mehr, 62, 63 Stunden,
sind das 900 bis 1000 Euro
das ist richtig
also musst du noch Steuern drauf bezahlen
das ist richtig gut bezahlt
dementsprechend gibt es
bei uns eigentlich auch keine
Knappheit an Leuten
die gerne Wochenendbereitschaft machen
Ich erinnere mich, dass ich meinen ersten Anruf vor ein paar Tagen filmen wollte, aber es war so stressig, dass ich es nicht konnte.
Ich arbeitete von 8 Uhr bis 8 Uhr jeden Tag und hatte nicht mal Zeit, um zu essen.
Nice.
Boah, das würd ich jetzt auch reinhauen.
On Call sollte doch eigentlich nicht sein.
Es ist permanent was,
du musst dich permanent drum kümmern,
sondern es ist die Ausnahme, das was ist.
Und du kannst halt, wenn was wirklich dringend ist,
an einem dringenden System auch nachts angerufen werden.
Aber denen scheint ja On Call
letztendlich eher
Sklavenausbeutung
24-7-Arbeit zu sein,
wie es sich bisher anhört.
Wie ist es bei euch am Abend in der Nacht während der Woche mit Bereitschaft,
du hast das Handy neben dem Bett liegen und wenn was ist, dann kriegst du, dann klingelt es.
Also entweder rufen dich Leute an, das ist aber relativ selten,
meistens ist halt das Monitoring was feststellst, irgendwas kaputt gegangen.
Also nachts angerufen wirst du selten.
Du wirst eher, sagen wir mal, Sonntagvormittag angerufen,
wenn irgendeiner merkt, oh, da ist was nachts kaputt gegangen und wir müssten mal gucken und so.
Wenn es nachts klingelt, dann ist es meistens automatische Monitoring-Meldung.
Und bei uns ist es allerdings auch so eingestellt, dass nicht jede Monitoring-Meldung automatisch an den Bereitschaftstyp eskaliert wird,
sondern nur die, die kritisch sind und auch nur die von kritischen Systemen.
Das heißt, es ist schon mal eingeschränkt.
Ja, aber sagen wir jetzt, wenn irgendein Handelssystem für was Wichtiges zuständig ist, wenn das jetzt nicht geht, dann kann es durchaus sein, dass Sonntag dann auch das Handy bimmelt.
Also erstmal, was lernen wir Oncall erstmal ordentlich fressen?
Erstmal schön reinhauen.
Und jetzt klingelt gleich das Handy.
Und er muss los.
Und die Hälfte essen stehen lassen.
Free Daily Drink.
Da habe ich ja auch immer den Eindruck,
also, ne, so dieses
Free Sachen, so nach dem Motto,
das ist eigentlich nur, dass die Leute sich verpflichteter
fühlen der Firma gegenüber, weil man hat ja auch
was for free gekriegt.
Guck mal, der hat Hardtop offen, oder?
Sieht das nicht ein bisschen aus wie Hardtop?
Hä?
Ah, nicht ganz, oder?
Moment, Moment, warum werden die DDoS von ihren eigenen Leuten?
Hat irgendeine Mistyploid, ha?
Aber einen Test sollte man doch nicht machen in einer Zeit, wo einer on call hat am Wochenende oder sonst wobei.
Warum wippen die beide mit dem Fuß? Weil die so voll mit Energydrinks und Kaffee sind, dass die nicht mehr zur Ruhe kommen.
Und so gestresst sind, dass die wahrscheinlich nach zwei Jahren in Rente müssen, wenn sie das gemacht haben.
Da hat einer Mist deployed, würde ich sagen.
und jetzt ist der service kaputt
das ist halt auch so ein ding bei uns auf der arbeit auch so man hat es man
kann man kann es sich man kann das selbst schlecht greifen aber wenn halt
sachen länger weg sind da geht es wirklich in die millionen gleich jetzt
Vielleicht nicht Sonntag, da passiert wenig, aber wenn es dann montags nicht zur Verfügung steht, das geht recht schnell in die Millionen.
Das kann man sich immer gar nicht richtig vorstellen.
Na geil.
Die meisten hocken doch eh nur, also zumindest ist es bei uns immer so, die meisten hocken in so einem Emergency Call drin und können eigentlich gar nicht wirklich was dazu beitragen.
und die, die was dazu beitragen können,
die würden wahrscheinlich besser dran tun
und wenn schneller mit der Arbeit fertig ist, sie müssten nicht in diesem
Call permanent hocken, sondern könnten was fixen.
Ja, kann ich vorstellen.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, das werde ich
nie verstehen. Ich werde es nie verstehen,
warum das, und es scheint ja sogar
bei Amazon so gemacht zu werden,
Warum das so ist, kann mich noch dran erinnern, in der alten Firma war das so gang und gäbe, dass wenn was kaputt gegangen ist, dann stand der Abteilungsleiter hinter dir, dein Chef hinter dir, alle gingen dir die permanent auf den Sack und in der Zeit sollst du dann nachdenken und irgendwas lösen.
Denn, ganz ehrlich, aus meiner Sicht müsste das so sein, die ganzen Leute, die eigentlich eh nur Management und Koordinationsaufgaben haben, die sollen sich in einen Raum setzen oder in ein Teams-Meeting hocken und sonst was.
Und die Leute, die die Sache fixen, die sollen in einen ruhigen Raum, in ein ruhiges eigenes Ding, was auch immer, denen soll man ihre Ruhe lassen, dass die den Kram fixen können.
Man kann sagen, okay, einmal in der Stunde Updates,
Ding, sind einer von den anderen Kamer rüber und sagen, was ist, wie sieht's.
Aber man muss die Leute arbeiten lassen.
Niemand kann ordentlich was auf die Reihe kriegen,
wenn zig Leute hinter einem rumtanzen.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Das glaube ich ihm nicht. Das sagt er, weil er in diesem Mindset drin ist. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es eine Great Learning Experience war.
Die Diamanten werden auch unter Druck gefarmt. Das ist der dümmste Spruch dazu überhaupt.
Man könnte es auch Schichtübergabe nennen.
Also es hat,
bei meinem neuen Arbeitgeber weiß ich es nicht,
bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber, der 24-7-Support,
der hat das auch immer gemacht.
Das weiß ich, weil ich dort in der Nähe gehockt habe. Die haben auch immer morgens und abends einmal Schichtübergabe gemacht und die hatten auch so ein Dokument. Das scheint ziemlich Standard zu sein.
Da fehlt aber eh die Hälfte.
Also, auch wenn es so ein Dokument gibt und eine Ticketzusammenfassung und sonst wie,
da fehlt eh immer die Hälfte und wichtigen Infos, soweit ich das mitgekriegt habe.
Und wisst ihr, das war so ein typischer, das war eines der Beispiele jetzt,
eines der Gründe, warum ich beim alten Arbeitgeber, also mit, nicht der Hauptgrund,
am 1 Sekunde, warum ich damit weg bin,
weil die teilweise
echt, wie nennt man das, so ein bisschen
toxic working culture
untereinander hatten, also ich hab das
mitgekriegt, ich hab ja dort in der Nähe gesessen,
es war so, sagen wir mal, vormittags
gab es irgendwie einen Ausfall,
der Support hat sich damit auseinandergesetzt,
so, und dann
ging es wieder, und sagen wir mal,
dann 18 Uhr,
oder, nee, wir müssen anders sagen,
Übergabe, Übergabe, sagen wir mal nachts,
müssen wir anders sagen, es muss ja was sein, wo ich es
mitgekriegt habe, 18 Uhr habe ich es ja nicht mitgekriegt,
Übergabe morgens, ja, also nachts
war was kaputt, es wurde wieder gefixt, alles gut,
man hat das Ganze morgens dann um
halb 8, 8 übergeben,
so eine Schichtübergabe habe ich öfters auch mitgekriegt,
wie gesagt, ich saß da in der Nähe,
war ein relativ großes Büro, da hat man das mitgekriegt,
wurde das übergeben,
Ticketzusammenfassung und alles,
so, und dann war mittags
noch irgendwas, oder es war mittags noch
irgendwie so ein retrospektiven
Call oder sowas, wo man dann gucken
wollte, ey, was war denn
mittags. Erstens waren bei meinem alten
Arbeitgeber solche Retrospektiv-Meetings
eher so ein
Blaming-Game,
so ein Schuldzuweisungs-Ding, so wer hat's
verkackt, wer hat's verschissen,
dementsprechend unkooperativ waren
die Leute auch da mitzuarbeiten, um wirklich zu gucken,
was dann kaputt war. Zumindest
eines der Hauptaussagen oder eines der
Aussagen, die da oft kam, war
also
war da jemand vom Support mit dabei,
ich war auch mit dabei,
von meinem Team, ja, als
Abgesandter von meinem Team war ich auch mit dabei.
So, und da wurde dann gesagt,
ja, gestern Abend um
weiß ich nicht,
0 Uhr 35
hat das Monitoring
angeschlagen. Da kam dann irgendein anderer Typ,
der sagte, ja, also laut meinen Infos
bestand das Problem aber schon seit 9 Uhr
28. Und dann hat dann der
Typ vom Support gesagt, kann ich nichts zu
sagen. Monitoring-Meldungen
haben das und das gesagt und in
Tickets war auch nichts zu sehen. Ich denke,
ihr macht immer eine Schichtübergabe und wisst über alles
Bescheid, hat ein anderer Typ
gesagt. Und wenn ich solche
Dinger schon gehört habe, da war ich schon
immer auf 180 und immer kurz vorm Ausfilm,
weil ich mir gedacht habe, Alter, denkt der Typ
wirklich, dass das in irgendeiner Art und Weise
dazu beiträgt, dass jetzt
das Problem für die Zukunft
nachhaltig gefixt wird?
Ernsthaft, meint
das wirklich irgendjemand?
Da habe ich mich schon immer auf...
Ich war da meistens nur, ich hab da meistens nur
dabei gehockt.
Als Vertreter von
Linux-Administration-Seite.
Immer, immer, immer
dabei gehockt. Das war regelmäßig.
Es wurde so
toxic geätzt über
diesen Support bei uns immer.
Wo ich mir auch immer
gedacht hab, denkt, ja,
weil die irgendwie halt auch angreifbar
waren, als die halt dies als erstes
mitkriegen, als erstes eskalieren, als erstes
sich drauf einloggen. Das war aber
in einer Art und Weise, das war
eines der Gründe mit, warum
ich da auch keinen Bock mehr drauf hatte, auf den Laden.
Ne, das hilft nicht, das hilft nicht.
Wahrscheinlich war es sogar,
wahrscheinlicher war es sogar so,
dass derjenige, aus der Richtung das kam,
der wahrscheinlich in seinem Team
festgestellt hat, fuck, wir haben es verkackt.
Wir haben irgendwie eine Dependency-File
nicht geupdatet und deswegen ist es kaputt gegangen.
Erstmal, erstmal auf
Angriff schalten, dass keiner auf die Idee kommt,
die eigenen Leute hätten es verkackt. Und es gab
so ein paar Kandidaten, die waren prinzipiell drauf.
Ich habe jetzt gehört, by the way, hören,
sagen. Ich gehe ja noch ab und zu
mal, das ist jetzt,
wie gesagt, es ist kein Witz, das ist
in der alten Firma, wo ich gearbeitet habe,
wirklich so. Ich gehe ja
ab und zu immer noch Mittagessen mit ein paar
alten Kollegen von der alten Arbeit. Wie gesagt,
mein neuer Arbeitgeber ist
800 Meter Luftlinie vom alten weg.
Frankfurt, Bahnhofsviertel,
Versicherungen, Banken und so,
ist alles auf einem Haufen.
und ich war letztens erst wieder Mittagessen, war einer von der alten Firma mit dabei
und er hat ernsthaft erzählt, das ist kein Witz, ich habe es ihm erst selbst nicht geglaubt,
hat gesagt, ey Max, der so und so ist jetzt auch neuer Abteilungsleiter,
den so und so kannte ich noch von früher, der war damals schon immer abfuck,
mit dem der immer Schnitzel geklaut, nein, erstens hat er nicht immer Schnitzel geklaut,
sondern nur einmal eine Schnitzel geklaut und zweitens ist, mit dem habe ich nichts mehr zu tun,
der Schnitzel geklaut hat.
Und hat gemeint, hier, der So-und-So
ist jetzt auch Abteilungsleiter.
Ich hab gesagt, ach so, okay, das ist ja bestimmt ätzend.
Hat er gemeint, ja, das ist ätzend.
Und er hat am ersten Tag, und das muss man sich mal
auf der Zunge zergehen lassen,
der Typ ist bekannt dafür, dass er gerne ausflippt.
Der Typ hat am ersten Tag
ein Guide rumgeschickt,
wie man mit ihm
zusammenarbeiten soll.
Dass er nicht so schnell ausflippt,
so nach dem Motto.
Also wie man mit ihm zu arbeiten hat,
dass er sich nicht aufregt.
Wo man sich denkt, wie zum
Teufel werden solche Leute
Abteilungsleiter?
Leute, die absolut komplett
unfähig sind,
mit anderen Leuten zusammenarbeiten,
in einer Position, wo es hauptsächlich um
übergreifende Zusammenarbeit geht.
Ja, das würde man von, von,
keine Ahnung, Overwatch
Ranked Cube bräuchte man sowas.
Der hat wirklich einen Guide rumgeschickt, wie man mit ihm umgehen soll, dass er sich nicht aufregt.
Das ist doch aber ein generelles Problem, oder nicht, dass die meisten Leute, die aufsteigen, sind, die es nicht können.
Das ist ein generelles Problem, wenn die jeweilige Unternehmenskultur und Firma das fördert und mitmacht.
Ja, wenn man das gescheit macht, nicht.
Aber in meiner alten Firma war das tatsächlich
eines der Gründe, warum ich da keinen Bock mehr hatte drauf.
Bist du in den Meetings auch immer so stö...
Ich mach doch hier gar nichts.
Ich reg mich über Leute auf, die sich nicht ordentlich verhalten.
Ich bin ein bisschen...
Egal, wir gucken erst mal weiter.
Ich muss euch noch, ich muss euch noch,
Fun Fact, Fun Fact.
Der gleiche Kollege, der mir das erzählt hat,
mit dem Guide rumgeschickt,
der hat ja mit dem Typ schon öfters Probleme gehabt.
Und wisst ihr, was er zu dem gesagt hat?
Da wäre ich gerne dabei gewesen.
Also, der Typ, der einen Guide rumgeschickt hat,
wie man mit ihm zusammenarbeiten soll,
dass er sich nicht aufregt,
der Kollege, der mir das erzählt hat,
dass der andere den Guide rumgeschickt hat,
der ist mit ihm schon auseinandergeraten.
Und wisst ihr, was er ihm gesagt hat?
In einem der ersten Meetings,
wo es er ihm gesagt hat,
du Würstchen hast mir nichts zu sagen.
Da könnt ihr euch überlegen, wie der an die Decke gegangen ist, Alter.
Da wäre ich gern dabei gewesen.
Aber der ist immer noch da.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das finde ich ist auch nicht die feine Art.
Beides nicht, beides nicht.
Also ich finde, das ist beides nicht, sollte beides nicht,
Daily gemeinsam miteinander
zusammenarbeiten sein. Das eine nicht
und das andere nicht.
Und das war eines der Gründe, warum ich auf die alte Firma
auch keinen Bock mehr hatte.
Aber da wäre ich gerne dabei gewesen.
Okay, weiter.
Oh, der Rücken, Alter.
Okay,
54 PM, das ist 17.44 Uhr, oder?
Keiner mehr da.
Wisst ihr, für mich ist on call.
Für mich ist 24-7 on call.
Sowas wie, es passiert nie was
und wenn mal was passiert, ist halt einer da.
Aber bei denen ist es ja
24-7 im Büro
und es ist immer was.
Was ist das denn? Es ist doch nicht on call.
das ist käfig haltung von von admins ja das ist nicht schlimm das ist auch überhaupt nicht
schlimm keiner kann alles wissen und die am meisten so tun als wissen sie alles wissen
auch nicht alles.
Alter, das ist 24-7, der kann nie heimgehen.
Die Support-Tickets werden nie
aufhören. Der wird nie alles abgearbeitet
haben.
The fuck? Das ist 24-7
Kreisekrei.
Anmenschrägschichtentwicklerentwicklerkäfighaltung im Büro.
Ja, was anderes kriegst du doch im Kopf gar nicht mehr hin nach der Zeit.
Ja, und jetzt wird er angerufen daheim.
Es ist jetzt komplett dunkel draußen.
Es ist Zeit, mich zu gehen.
Ich bin auf dem Weg, um etwas zu essen.
Ich denke, ich werde ein paar Chipotle auf dem Weg nach Hause holen.
Hoffentlich werde ich nicht verpastet.
Die Tasche ist versichert.
Das ist der hardcore Kreisel-Crime, was der macht.
Volle Arbeitstag.
Und wenn du verhungerst?
Bekommt er wenigstens 200.000 plus für das?
Das kann durchaus sein, aber die Gehälter in den USA sind eh deutlich höher.
Wieso ist sowas erlaubt?
Weil Freedom...
Ich komme gleich zurück.
Es ist gar nicht möglich, das gescheit einzustellen.
Aber bei uns auf der Arbeit ist es auch so,
es gibt Systeme, die schmeißen am laufenden Band
irgendwelche Warnings über nichts.
Und es gibt andere Systeme, die sind fast am Arsch
und schmeißen gar nichts.
Clues of different sources.
Das geht mir bei uns, wenn ich morgens als erster
da bin oder frühmäßig
für Tickets und so zuständig bin, geht mir das
auch so. Gerade bei Services, wo ich
keine Ahnung von habe, dann ist es auch immer so ein bisschen
Detektivarbeit.
Und wisst ihr was,
ohne Scheiß, was ist,
Chad, was meint ihr, was ist
die beste Dokumentation für Linux-Systeme?
Oder die beste Dokumentation für Linux-Systeme?
Oder notgedrungen
die beste Dokumentation für Linux-Systeme?
Shell History, richtig
Shell History
die eigene Shell History
und noch viel mehr die Shell History von anderen Leuten
also gerade bei Services
wo ich keine Ahnung von hab
logge ich mich ein, werde root
selbstverständlich, als andere drunter mache ich es nicht
werde root und gucke erstmal
in der Shell History, was die anderen Leute
gemacht haben, ob da irgendwas drin ist, was
so ungefähr aussieht, wie nach dem
was ich suche
Manpage bringt dir gar nichts bei solchen Fehlern
Manipatch bringt dir was, wenn du wissen willst, welcher Parameter für ein Kommando oder so.
Ne, Shell History. Shell History. Musst du gucken.
Und wenn du die Shell History unter root nicht bringst, dann greppst du in der Shell History in den Home Directories von den anderen Usern.
Und zu 90% findest du was, weil die Probleme treten ja nicht neu auf.
Also die allerwenigsten Probleme, mit denen man konfrontiert wird auf Services, die man nicht kennt, sind noch nie da gewesen.
90% Shell History.
90% findet ihr was.
Man findet da auch Passwörter und alles mögliche,
wenn die Leute sich vertippt haben.
Ja, aber Shell History.
Shell History ist das Beste.
Man könnte sagen,
man könnte auch im Ticketsystem gucken,
allerdings haben so ziemlich alle Ticketsysteme,
die mir einfallen,
eine notorisch beschissene Suchfunktion.
Selbst Jira hat eine Kack-Suchfunktion,
aber die geht noch halbwegs.
Aber alle anderen,
also die meisten anderen Ticketsysteme
haben noch schlechtere Suchfunktionen als Jira.
Ich weiß gar nicht,
wie man das in so eine...
Warum schaffen das alle Ticketsysteme,
die Suchfunktion so unglaublich zu
verkacken?
Das ist eigentlich eines der
zentralsten Sachen für ein Ticketsystem.
Wisst ihr, was
der schlimmste Ticketsystem ist, was ich kenne?
Was ich mal benutzen musste,
musste,
weil Teile von der alten Firma
das benutzt haben und ich ab und zu mal
da auch reingucken musste
Helpline, richtig, Helpline
woher weißt du, dass das Helpline schlecht ist?
Helpline, benutzt ihr auch Helpline?
oder habe ich das schon ein paar mal erzählt?
Helpline, Helpline ist das
schlimmste Ticketsystem, was ich persönlich je gesehen habe
ich zeige euch nur mal das UI
dann wisst ihr schon Bescheid
damals gab es einen desktop client
war das nicht aus so sah das nie
das dass die scheinen auch ihr design laufend laufen zu ändern
das war eine Urhalt-WPF-Anwendung,
Windows-Only,
und,
oder vielleicht Windows Forms, weiß ich nicht,
ja, so ungefähr sah das aus,
aber anders,
anders, blauer,
ja, Windows-Only,
Desktop-Anwendung
für das Ticketsystem,
Web-Interface kam erst später,
das war das schlimmste,
am Start das nervigste, schlimmste Ticketsystem,
mit dem ich hier arbeiten musste.
Die haben hier laufend neue Designs.
Das sieht alles immer anders aus.
ServiceNow.
Es sei denn, ServiceNow ist so verkustomized,
dass wieder nichts funktioniert.
Sprecher aus Erfahrung.
ServiceNow ist
grausam Business Enterprise Software.
Da ist mir Jira um ein tausendfaches
lieber. Wobei man halt sagen muss,
ServiceNow ist halt meistens auch noch deutlich mehr integriert.
Also wenn eine Firma
ServiceNow hat, dann
ist das so tief
drin, dass da quasi alles auch
customised ist und auch ganz viel
Workflows dran angeschlossen sind und sowas.
Ja, das trifft's.
Das trifft's am ehesten.
Lucky, dankeschön für den
Pog-Subscription. Aber jetzt schauen wir
das Video fertig.
Deswegen gucke ich da solche Videos gerne,
weil ich da gefühlt jede halbe Minute was erzählen kann irgendwann, was mal gewesen ist.
Und was?
Ich habe mal eine blöde Frage.
Warum braucht der Customer das abends um 19 Uhr?
Okay, vielleicht ist der Customer in einer anderen Zeitzone und bei dem ist es 12 Uhr.
Ja, okay.
Ja, aber dann ist On-Call wirklich 24-7-Admin-Käfighaltung bei denen.
dieses Problem im Vergangenen.
Was ich hier mache, ist,
die gleichen Prozeduren zu untersuchen
und zu versuchen, die Grundkosten zu bestimmen.
kaputt ist, dann gehe ich
ans Telefon, gehe an den Rechner und gucke mir
das mit den Leuten an, die auch
Rufbereitschaft haben.
Wenn da noch was wäre,
würde ich sagen,
Leute, also
es ist nachts um drei, ich bin jetzt schon
damit beschäftigt, was anderes,
was ist jetzt wichtiger?
Und wenn keiner der Leute, wenn man sich
da nicht einigt ist, dann
rufe ich meinen Chef an.
Das ist in dem Fall tatsächlich
ganz einfach. Wenn die Leute
nicht in der Lage wären, nachts um drei
zu sagen, das ist wichtiger als das
von sich aus, dann würde ich meinen
Chef anrufen und sagen, Chef, guck mal, ist zwar
sehr selten, aber jetzt ist es vorgekommen.
Wir haben drei kritische Fehler
nachts um drei.
Wir müssen jetzt noch mehr Leute
anrufen oder du musst mir
sagen, was davon wichtiger ist.
Also ich würde, dann würde ich echt,
also wenn es soweit ist, dass ich nicht weiterkomme,
nachts um drei und ich bombardiert werde
mit mehreren Tickets und Leuten, die meinten,
Jens ist jetzt das Wichtigste, dann würde ich
meinen Chef anrufen. Ist noch nie vorgekommen, ich denke
auch nicht, dass es in nächster Zeit vorkommt,
aber in dem Fall ist das Einfachste und Beste, was man
machen kann, das Weitereskalieren,
dann ist man nämlich fein raus.
Dann kann keiner im Nachhinein sagen,
Max, du hast aber
das an der Stelle zuerst
gemacht, du hättest das machen müssen oder das ist
doch wichtiger, das weiß man doch. Dann sagen, ey,
ich hab meinen Chef gefragt, der hat gesagt,
ich soll das machen, wenn du Probleme damit hast,
geh zu meinem Chef.
das ist auch was, was man lernen muss mit der Zeit
man muss nicht alles selber lösen
also gerade Sachen
die nichts mit der Technik zu tun haben
ist manchmal besser
man versucht gar nicht, sich da irgendwie
selbst was zurechtzureimen, sondern sagt
geh zu meinem Chef
frag den und wenn der sagt
ich soll deins zuerst machen, dann mach ich das
und die meisten haben damit auch kein Problem
die machen das dann
oder aber in 90% der Fällen machen sie es nicht und es ist halt nicht so wichtig.
So würde ich das auch handhaben.
Der Anruf, der zuerst gekommen ist, ist der, woran ich schon beschäftigt bin.
Es sei denn, ich weiß halt, das kann natürlich auch sein,
mein ganzes Gehirn abschalten darf man nicht.
Sagen wir mal, Samstagmittag ruft jemand an,
weil irgendwelche Jobs nicht gelaufen sind,
die irgendwann erst, keine Ahnung, Montagabends zum Businessabschluss gebraucht werden,
dann würde ich sagen, okay, wenn jetzt gleichzeitig noch jemand anruft und sagt,
irgendwelche Handelsplattformen sowieso ist kaputt und die brauchen die Leute,
wenn die Börse öffnet, Montag 8 Uhr, dann würde ich von mir aus sagen schon,
okay, das scheint ja wichtiger zu sein.
Und in der Regel wird dann auch der andere sagen, ja, dann ist das wichtiger als meins,
was erst um 18 Uhr drankommt.
Aber wenn die sich beide nicht einig sind und beide sagen, nein, du musst jetzt meins bearbeiten,
der andere sagt, nein, du musst jetzt meins bearbeiten,
dann würde ich meinen Chef anrufen, würde ich sagen, ey,
ich habe hier zwei, die der Meinung sind, ihre Sachen sind beide ultra wichtig,
ich kann mir aber gerade nur eins angucken.
Vielleicht hängt ja beides auch zusammen.
Ist ja oftmals auch so.
Also wenn es Probleme gibt und dann weitere Probleme zur gleichen Zeit auftreten,
ist die Chance hoch, dass das irgendwie miteinander zusammenhängt.
So, aber jetzt weiter gucken.
um die Grundkosten zu bestätigen.
Es ist jetzt 7 Uhr.
Ich bin noch am arbeiten.
Ich habe mein Chipotle gerade fertig gemacht.
Das ist klar.
Spiel nicht mit mir.
Hat er dann auch das Notebook auf dem Klo mit dabei?
Das ist schön.
Toll, ein anderer macht's.
Wisst ihr, wofür Team steht.
Ja, Ticket Redirect ist auch immer gut.
Oder, oder, was, wisst ihr,
pass auf, ich erzähl euch jetzt
Lifehack schlechthin,
wenn ihr
Freitagabend als letzter da seid,
eigentlich weg wollt,
aber seht, da ist noch ein Ticket drinnen
und ein Ticket,
wo da steht, ähm,
wo irgendeine SLA
abläuft oder sowas, ja?
So, so nach dem Motto, sollte innerhalb von zwei Stunden bearbeitet werden.
Jetzt kommt Lifehack, was ihr dann macht.
Man geht ja davon aus, die anderen sind auch schon weg.
Dann macht ihr nämlich den Microsoft Move.
Dann schreibt ihr in das Ticket rein,
ah, hier scheint es ein Problem zu geben, dass die Festplatte voll läuft.
Ich bin mir allerdings nicht sicher, welche Logs entfernt werden können.
Laut Hochrechnung vom Monitoring hält der Plattenplatz aber noch bis Dienstag.
Und dann sagt ihr Ticketstatus Waiting Customer.
Dann ist das nämlich von euch weg.
Und es liegt wieder bei demjenigen, der das Ticket aufgemacht hat.
Der ist aber schon weg.
Das heißt, bis Montag passiert nichts.
So muss man das machen.
Und dann macht ihr Aufschluss und seid weg.
GG Eats.
Moment, ich hab's gar nicht verpasst.
Jetzt ist 8 und er ist fertig.
Doch, bam.
Alter.
ach du scheiße ganz ehrlich wenn ich das so sehe dann verstehe ich also wenn das
zufälligerweise auch die gleichen leute sind die auf customer tickets auch
antworten oder nicht die kleine ähnliche schicht dass die keinen bock haben
verstehe ich
und dann hast du jemanden, der auf der Gegenseite
es wirklich braucht und schreibt Freitag um
23 Uhr, dann wird eben die Rufbereitschaft
aktiviert, wenn er es wirklich braucht. Und es
für den Service ist ja als kritisch eingestuft, ansonsten
hat er Pech.
Also weil der Microsoft
Move, der Oracle Move, der Google Move,
was auch immer, in Support Tickets
ist ja prinzipiell eigentlich
nichts Bedeutsames reinzuschreiben.
Also die Standardantwort von
Google auf ein Ticket ist, zum Beispiel
Beispiel aktuell. Ihr wisst ja, ich arbeite in einem Projekt, wo es um Blockchain und Kryptowährungen geht. Bin ich dabei. Und dort kommt es manchmal vor, dass eine KI-gestützte Erkennung bei Google Krypto-Miner auf unseren VMs erkennt.
die gar keine Krypto-Miner sind.
Und dann schickt Google eine Meldung,
Achtung, wir haben einen Krypto-Miner gefunden,
ihr System ist wahrscheinlich kompromittiert.
Und außerdem möchten wir Sie nochmal darauf hinweisen,
dass Krypto-Mining auf unsere normalen VMs nicht erlaubt ist.
Und daraufhin haben wir mit einem Ticket gemacht bei Google,
haben gesagt, Google, wie kommt ihr da eigentlich drauf?
dass das ein Krypto-Miner ist,
beziehungsweise, dass diese Kommunikation
irgendwie was mit Krypto-Mining zu tun hat.
Und dann antwortet Google immer drauf,
das wirkt fast wie ein bisschen AI-Zusammenfassung,
also du machst ein Ticket auf,
sagst hier, da und da die Kommunikation,
das ist, wie kommt ihr da drauf,
dass das Mining ist,
wir machen kein Mining und bla bla bla
und die Antwort, paar Tickets,
das ist bei Microsoft, Oracle und Google ähnlich,
Das ist immer, die schreiben dein eigenes Ticket in der ersten Antwort, schreiben die das ein bisschen um, so nach dem Motto, ah, ich sehe, sie haben eine Anfrage gestellt zum Thema Netzwerkkommunikation.
Und dann schreibt Google immer noch gerne rein, nach tiefgreifender Analyse, also sie schreiben das auf Englisch, also after thoroughly investigation bla bla bla, also nach tiefgreifender Analyse haben wir festgestellt, dass diese Kommunikation wahrscheinlich zu Traffic, zu einer, im Prinzip schreiben die genau das, was du in das Ticket schon reingeschrieben hast, nur dass sie davor schreiben, nach gründlicher Untersuchung haben wir festgestellt,
Und dann schreiben sie deinen Text etwas umgeändert wieder rein.
Und ich bin mir eigentlich mittlerweile zu 99% sicher,
das ist nicht, weil die dich ärgern wollen,
das ist nur zum SLRs einhalten.
Das ist nur zum SLRs einhalten.
Die eigentliche Analyse wird wahrscheinlich irgendwann irgendwo schon noch stattfinden,
aber nicht in der SLR-Zeit.
Und wenn Google das macht, warum soll man es nicht auch machen?
Und nachdem ich das Video hier jetzt geguckt habe,
oder wir das Video gerade gucken,
und die Support-Leute bei Google auch solche Schichten machen wie der,
kann ich mir vorstellen, warum die so wenig Bock haben, wirklich tiefgreifende Analyse zu machen.
Weil die schon seit 18 Stunden am Start sind und ein weiteres Ticket reinkommt und sie eigentlich keinen Bock mehr haben.
Was ist ein SLA? Ein Service Level Agreement.
Da steht zum Beispiel drin, wenn ein Ticket aufgeht, muss innerhalb von zwei Stunden darauf reagiert werden.
Was da nicht so genau drin steht, ist wie diese Reaktion auszusehen hat.
Oder so schwammig, dass eben solche vagen Antworten als wir halten uns dran gilt.
Boah, Alter, wann hat der angefangen?
Montagsmorgens irgendwann.
Check the updates.
Oh, the ticket?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Huge shout out to Amon for reaching out to help in the middle of the night when I didn't even ask.
As he mentioned, usually when you're stuck on a customer impacting issue like this for too long
and don't know how to solve or mitigate it, you can always feel free to page another teammate
or even your manager for support.
In this case, however, it was probably what I should have done,
but one, I wanted to figure it out on my own,
and two, I didn't think it was that big of an issue.
Yeah, wahrscheinlich. Ich weiß, das kommt auch ein bisschen auf die Kultur an.
So nach dem Motto, offiziell, also ich weiß ja nicht, wie es da ist, aber es könnte ja auch so sein, dass es ist.
Offiziell heißt es, okay, wenn du nicht weiterkommst, kannst du jederzeit einen Teammate oder deinen Manager pagen.
Und unterschwellig heißt es dann, mach das aber bloß nicht, das wird nicht gerne gesehen.
Das kommt ja auf die Kultur in dem Laden an.
Ja, ich habe wieder regelmäßig Streams.
Manager anrufen.
Siehste?
Er hat meinen Lifehack direkt implementiert.
Einfach mit irgendwas antworten und hoffen, der andere ist jetzt auch ins Bett gegangen.
Alter.
Was hat er jetzt? 18 Stunden Arbeitstag oder wie?
Darkstar, danke für den Sub.
Und das die ganze Woche. Wie soll das funktionieren, Alter?
Ne, 12 Stunden hat er bisher. Und das die ganze Woche.
Und nachts kann er auch angerufen werden.
Man schläft nachts ja auch nicht richtig, wenn du weißt, permanent kann das Handy klingeln.
Oh, ne.
What the fuck?
Ich glaube, ich habe einige Liede gefunden, aber nichts Konkretes.
Ich werde es eine Nacht für wirklich nennen, keine Arbeit mehr.
Ich werde es in der Morgen wieder holen.
Guten Morgen, alle.
so nach dem motto ja oder ist er wirklich verpflichtet dieses ticket jetzt zu bearbeiten
je nachdem welche prio sonst das wissen wir jetzt ja alles nicht
Was?
Irgendein Smoothie.
Boah.
Erstmal halbnackig in Videocall joinen.
Aber es ist nichts zu schlecht.
Und es ist das gleiche Problem wie gestern.
Okay.
Ich habe es vergessen.
zu schlafen arbeiten arbeiten essen
ist jetzt ins büro gefahren weil es pflicht des büro anwesenheit hat der
eigenen manager ausgedacht wir können nur richtig zusammenarbeiten wenn wir im
büro sind weil ja auch das zwischenmenschliche so wichtig ist oder
sowas ansonsten wäre ich einfach daheim am laptop geblieben
... und was wir heute planen.
Aber es ist auch eine gute Möglichkeit,
irgendwelche großen Probleme oder Blocker zu nennen,
die uns zu dem offenen Team schlagen.
Die Idee ist, dass jemand Insights oder Lösungen hat,
um dich zu unblockieren,
was ich hier genau mache.
Was?
Dass jemand Insights oder Lösungen hat,
um dich zu unblockieren,
was ich hier genau mache.
hier
niemand hat mehr kommentare, ich denke, wir sind bereit, okay, ich habe noch ein paar
mehr, kann ich mir ein paar holen
ja es ist aber
problematische probleme, die ich gestern Abend gearbeitet habe und zu diesem Punkt habe ich endlich die
der Grundkost, nachdem die Teamleute etwas Hilfe bekommen haben, während des Stand-Ups.
Jetzt schalten wir die Gears, um herauszufinden, wie wir es lösen.
Ungefähr die Frage ist, warum unser Cash nicht richtig geupdatet wird.
Und ich bin in die Code, um zu verstehen, warum und wie das Cash-Mechanismus funktioniert
und wo es vielleicht falsch gegangen ist.
Da kann ich mithalten.
Da habe ich auch...
Ich würde sogar sagen, ich habe mehr,
weil ich habe teilweise Termine.
Da überschneiden sich drei Termine.
Und jetzt nochmal Lifehack.
Manchmal gehe ich einfach zu allen drei nicht hin.
Pass mal auf, wir gucken jetzt mal
Just for fun, komm wir gucken mal wie es nächste Woche aussieht
Moment, wo hab ich mein Handy von der Arbeit
Äh, Moment
Teams
Ich glaube nächste Woche geht's halbwegs, so Teams
Also
Ähm
Okay, Dienstag
Daily Scrum geht's los.
9.30 Uhr, Daily Scrum.
Danach Team Daily,
danach irgendein Austausch-Talk um 13 Uhr.
14.30 Uhr,
Backlog Refinement,
Leute, Backlog Refinement.
Dann ist der Tag vorbei.
Also habe ich am Dienstag
theoretisch Zeit,
zwischen 10 und 13 Uhr
was zu arbeiten.
Danach ist wieder Meeting und davor ist Meeting.
Und dazwischen wird auch mal was gegessen.
aber beim Dienstag habe ich zwei Stunden Zeit, was zu arbeiten, okay?
So, mittwochs geht's los, 9 Uhr, neue News aus der IT, 9.30 Uhr Daily.
Ah, das ist ein schöner Tag.
Da habe ich 9 Uhr, 9 Uhr, also Mittwoch, 9 Uhr IT News, 9.30 Uhr Daily Scrum,
9.30 Uhr Service Meeting, 9.30 Uhr Operations Service Meeting.
Wo gehe ich denn da jetzt hin?
Gehe ich jetzt zum Service Meeting, zum Operations Service Meeting oder zum Daily Scrum?
Ich kann es euch sagen, ich gehe zum Daily Scrum.
Danach geht es weiter, 10.30 Uhr Support Call mit einem Dienstleister,
Leister, der eine Software für uns bereitstellt
und da dürfen wir regelmäßig
Fragen stellen oder sagen,
es funktioniert nicht richtig. 10.30 Uhr.
Dann 10.35 Uhr.
Ah, wie das passt. Ich habe
fünf Minuten Zeit zum Mieten gehabt.
10.35 Uhr
Teammeeting.
Nicht Teammeeting, also übergreifende
Gruppenmeeting. Dann
14 Uhr Teammeeting. Das heißt, ich kann
theoretisch
von
11, also zwei Stunden auch wieder
arbeiten an dem Tag.
Zwei Stunden arbeiten.
Und dann habe ich 15 Uhr
wieder Surefixe.
Austausch und Sync
Surefix.
Kommst du dann auch zum Arbeiten bei so vielen Meetings
und nicht ab und zu mal
so ein, zwei Stunden am Tag
oder so vielleicht.
So.
Dann, also haben wir
schon mal an zwei Tagen insgesamt so drei
bis vier Stunden, wo man was machen kann. Wahnsinn.
So, dann geht es weiter.
Donnerstag, 9.15 Uhr,
jour fix.
9.30 Uhr, Daily Scrum.
10 Uhr, Tech Talk.
10.30 Uhr, jour fix.
Okay, das überschneidet sich auch schon
wieder alles. Aber haltet,
Leute, keck wait, haltet euch
fest. Haltet euch fest. Am Donnerstag,
nachmittags, kein Meeting.
Das kann sich noch ändern.
Da kann noch was kommen.
also ab, sag mal, wenn ich
12.30 fertig
essen bin, bis
15 Uhr oder so
kann ich dann tatsächlich
mal zweieinhalb Stunden
also sind wir schon bei ungefähr sechseinhalb Stunden
also sag mal, realistisch, sechs Stunden
bis Donnerstag, wo ich was arbeiten
konnte, so, Freitag
geht's weiter, Daily Scrum
Community
sonst was, Call, keine Ahnung, whatever
Team Daily
Operations, Service Meeting
Blocker
Okay, Freitag
mache ich gar nichts. Also Freitag
geht's los.
Daily Scrum, 9.30 Uhr
Davor, okay, davor. Ich bin ja am meisten schon
um 8 oder so da. Davor kann ich das machen.
9.30 Uhr Daily Scrum
Dann 10.00 Uhr
Team Daily, 10.30 Uhr
Blocker für Sachen, die
ich euch jetzt nicht sagen kann.
Dann geht's, dann Mittagessen,
dann 13 Uhr irgendwelche Ansible-Workshop-Gedöns, 13.30 Uhr, Austausch mit Google haben wir dort zum Thema Blockchain, wo wir gerade dabei sind, vielleicht haben wir dann auch hier am Start, ah ne, Moment, das ist Amazon, verguckt, ne, den haben wir da garantiert nicht am Start und dann haben wir noch ein Friday-Abschluss-Dings-Call.
Also Freitag mache ich gar nicht.
Also realistisch zusammengefasst
habe ich ungefähr einen Arbeitstag
in vier Arbeitstagen.
Von der Zeit her.
Ich meckere da jedes Mal drüber.
Ich habe es mir nicht ausgesucht.
Ich habe schon ein paar Blocker.
Ja, was meinst du, warum ich an manchen Tagen
Zeit habe, weil ich da Blocker eingestellt habe?
Ich habe zum Beispiel jeden Tag ab 15.30 Uhr
im Blocker eingestellt, bis morgens
um 8.30 Uhr, dass keine auf die Idee
kommen, mich da einzuladen.
Also
verstanden haben die es. Mein Chef sagt es auch.
Mein Chef sagt, er hat die gleichen Probleme. Nur noch mehr.
Es geht so.
Ich mache deutlich mehr
Terraform-Cloud-Infrastruktur als Ansible.
Wobei man ja immer sagen muss,
Terraform und Ansible können sich auch gut ergänzen.
Das eine ist halt eher zum
Professionieren, das andere eher zum Konfigurieren, aber
es hat auch große Überschneidungen.
So, weiter geht's.
Oh, das braucht man natürlich.
Moment, was? Der ist heimgegangen?
Und jetzt hat er noch, wenn er daheim ist...
Moment, 9.20 Uhr. Meint er jetzt abends oder morgens?
Morgens, oder?
Was ist mit Open Tofu?
Ja, wenn ich Terraform meine, kannst du da Open Tofu einsetzen.
Mittwoch morgens, ja.
Ja, das brauchst du dann auch.
Warum musst du... Achso, das ist ja nicht...
Er ist ja nicht on call in der Zeit.
Er macht ja normalen Arbeitstag.
Plus on call, habe ich ja ganz vergessen.
Er macht 24-7 on call plus normalen Arbeitstag.
Das ist wirklich hart.
How to burn out Video.
Wisst ihr, was ich mich frage?
ob Amazon dieses Video absegnen musste oder nicht.
Ich würde sagen, Amazon musste das Video absegnen,
weil die sind da immer, ich könnte mir vorstellen,
die sind ganz furchtbar picky, was da erzählt wird.
Und ihr könnt euch vorstellen,
das ist ein schon von Amazon abgesegnetes Video.
Also geht mal davon aus,
die Realität ist noch deutlich weniger geschönt.
Also das meiste, was wir jetzt hier raus entnehmen können, ist zwischen den Zeilen und nicht das Wasser.
Quality is Destiny, das war doch auch Amazon, oder?
Das war das Team aus dem Amazon-Lager.
Quality is Destiny, alle einmal in Kreis stellen und Quality is Destiny schreiben.
No one here.
Hopefully it stays that way for the next hour.
Okay, keiner in das Meeting gekommen, Bessel.
Beste Meeting ist keine Meeting.
Ich finde es aber cool, dass beim Stand-up wenigstens keiner steht.
Ob Bezos auch so viel arbeitet, ehrlich gesagt, glaube ich das.
Ja, glaube ich.
Diese Arbeitskultur, die in diesen Unternehmen herrscht, liegt ja oftmals auch daran, dass die Manager und unter anderem auch damals die Gründer, dass die auch nach diesen Ansichten gelebt und gearbeitet haben.
Dass nicht jeder quasi den 24-7-Kreisel-Karriere-Crime machen will, ist denen komplett fremd.
Ihr müsst euch mal überlegen, was das heißt.
It's not XE, ihr müsst euch das mal überlegen, was das heißt.
Permanent, gehen wir mal 8 out of 10.
Der hat, das ist permanenter Workload und Stress 8 von 10.
Das ist für ihn die Baseline.
Das heißt, ja, es gibt noch schlimmere Teams, aber das ist heftig, oder?
Wenn das die Baseline ist, 8 von 10, was passiert dann, wenn es richtig stressig wird? 11 von 10?
Das muss man sich echt mal vorstellen.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob das Video von Amazon
abgesegnet ist. Das hätte mir bestimmt nicht gefallen.
Ja, Burnout Speedrun.
Wisst ihr was?
Wenn er dann auf dem Level ist, Senior zu sein,
dann sagt er, ich hab keinen Bock mehr, ich geh woanders hin.
Das stimmt.
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt.
Das fangt mich auch immer ab.
Wenn Leute kommen, Max, da geht was nicht.
Ich sage, ja, was denn genau? Ah, ich habe hier bloß so eine komische Fehlermeldung heute Morgen beim Anmelden gekriegt.
Ja, und? Hast du vielleicht irgendwas mit ein bisschen mehr Substanz?
Was soll ich jetzt machen? Hast du es nochmal ausprobiert? Ja, ich probiere es gerade nochmal aus. Ah, jetzt geht das einloggen. Ja, egal.
Das regt mich dann auch immer auf, sowas.
der rechte Reise. So können sie mich in die richtige Richtung bewegen, ohne mich durch
jede einzelne Schritt zu fahren. Es geht darum, ressourcengelblich zu sein und zu zeigen, dass
du den Eindruck hast, bevor du Hilfe suchst.
Es ist aktuell 5.19 Uhr. Ich denke, ich muss bald raus. Es gibt ein paar Probleme. Tim und
ich planen, am Samstag seinen Geburtstag ins Schnee zu fahren.
Ja, aber da wird er angerufen.
Das ist im Prinzip das, was ich am Anfang gesagt habe.
Es ist wirklich arbeiten, essen, arbeiten, arbeiten, arbeiten, nebenbei arbeiten, essen, versuchen zu schlafen, arbeiten, arbeiten, essen und das sieben Tage.
Was stand da? Susi?
Keine Ahnung.
Sass.
Ist das Toss-Musik?
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
Wobei das kann kein Toss sein, wenn das einfach so auf YouTube am Start ist.
Also, in den ARD-Beiträgen ist es Toss, aber hier ist es wahrscheinlich nicht Toss.
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
geht sowas überhaupt als Musik durch?
ernsthaft gefragt
das ist doch alles AI generated mittlerweile
das ist so 0815 generic
alles hört sich gleich an
also diese Sorte
von Musik
ja das ist ein bisschen wie Hintergrundrauschen
Du kannst theoretisch anstatt...
Ja gut, das hast du in Frankfurt auch in jeder Ecke.
Du kannst im Hintergrund auch einen Heizlüfter anmachen.
Pass auf, gleich wird er gepaged.
Mini-Burger.
Also das ist auch so, dass das Brot fettig
als Fuck ist und kaum was drauf ist.
Nix.
Und eine Gurke wahrscheinlich.
Also wenn du schon
Augentropfen brauchst,
dass du überhaupt den
arbeitstag durchhält schon krasse nein augen tropfen augen tropfen sollten
nicht essential for software engineers seien die sind sie vielleicht einmal 24
7 karriere kreisel kreis reingezwungen ist aber sie sollten nicht essential sein
Wie lange warst du gestern?
Gestern habe ich...
Seitdem ich am Montag bezahlt wurde, sind die Dinge relativ ruhig.
Ich habe mir die Zeit genommen, um ein paar ältere, höhere-Seviert-Tickets zu packen und auf die Dinge zu bleiben.
Ich meine, Ruhe essen kannst du da.
Ich glaube, das Essen ist wenigstens umsonst.
Every other week we have a lunch and learn session, which is just a meeting that occurs during lunch.
Lunch and learn, das ist auch so ein weiteres Ding.
Also, versteht mich nicht falsch, ich finde es prinzipiell nicht verkehrt.
Aber für mich klingt das so wie, man möchte die Leute indirekt ein bisschen da rein drücken, dass sie doch auch während ihrem Mittagessen arbeiten.
So nach dem Motto, na warst du diese Woche beim Learn & Launch?
und lektiere, während ich mich hart versuche, nicht schlafen zu lassen.
Wenn ich in Frankfurt bin, arbeite ich sogar auch oft während der Pause.
Ich gehe zum Bäcker, hole mir zwei, drei Brötchen und setze mich dann wieder an den Rechner und warte.
Ich bin ja da auch schuldig, was das angeht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das nicht mit dem Arbeit ist.
Tim und ich werden heute nach Arbeit bei REI ein paar Snowboardgears kaufen.
Und jetzt kaufe ich die Tickets für uns vier hier, was die Gears und Lessen betrifft,
da es unser erstes Mal ist, was ca. 200$ kostet.
Snowboarden scheint ein riesiges Ding zu sein, während des Winters in Seattle,
da es nichts anderes zu tun hat, also muss ich sehen, was die Hype ist.
Bleibt sicher, bis zum Ende dieses Videos zu bleiben, wenn ihr mich essen möchtet.
Es ist snowing, richtig? Ich denke, es ist snowing.
Was auch jetzt kaum steigt auf snowboard wird er angerufen
Nein das ist ja noch nicht wochenende
Also wir haben auch bei uns eine Kantine, aber da gehe ich selten hin.
Das liegt daran, dass ich verdauungsmäßig irgendwie vieles nicht so richtig gut vertrage.
Aber das ist jetzt nichts Neues.
Das liegt nicht, weil ich super gestresst bin oder so.
Das habe ich schon...
Ich gucke halt immer,
dass ich nicht zu viel Fett oder so,
nicht, dass ich Dünnschiss kriege.
Ist nichts Schlimmes.
Also wenn ich normal esse und nichts übertreibe,
habe ich gar keine Probleme.
Aber wenn ich mich zu sehr vollfutter
mit zu scharfem oder zu fettigem Zeug,
dann sitze ich auf der Arbeit
und muss laufen aufs Klo. Das ist nichts.
Ist ja was richtig, was richtig gut ist, wo wir gerade beim Essen Bahnhofsviertel sind,
wo ich echt gerne ab und zu mal hingehe.
weiß, es widerspricht jetzt
meiner Sache, scharf und fettig vertrage ich
nicht, aber das vertrage ich witzigerweise.
Beim Korean Fried Chicken
Frankfurt.
Cheeking.
Das hier, genau.
Das ist nice.
Die haben auch ein Mittagsmenü.
Das schmeckt richtig gut.
Ja, hier sieht man es, glaube ich.
Ja, Mittagsmenü.
da kannst du dann also dass er er ihr müsst das da er er das sagt das ist gut
Jan Jung Chicken
und das als Mittagsmenü
kostet 14 Euro 50
gibt's was zu trinken dabei
und
es ist
also man kriegt
Präzision Topf mit Freit schicken
kann ich auch so ein
um ich nehme letzter Zeit er mild weil ich nicht
das Risiko eingehen will, auf der Arbeit auf dem Klo zu hocken.
Und du kriegst Reis dabei,
kann nach Pommes frites, aber Reis,
kriegst ein bisschen Salat dabei
und mehr als genug. Also es reicht.
Ich finde 14,50 Euro ist halbwegs fair
und mir schmeckt es richtig gut aus.
Kann ich empfehlen, wenn ihr mal im Bahnhofsviertel seid
in Frankfurt.
Cheeking.
Warum gucken wir ihnen jetzt eigentlich zu,
wie er die Hose wechselt?
Gibt es veganes Chicken?
Geben wird es das bestimmt, aber dort
habe ich das noch nicht gesehen.
Gehst du wirklich nie aufs Klo im Büro?
Ne, ne, so war das nicht gemeint.
Ich meinte, wenn ich zu scharfes Essen esse,
ich will nicht mit Dünnschiss im Büro
aufs Klo wissen.
Ich gehe, wenn ich muss,
auch auf der Arbeit aufs Klo, wobei ich ungern
auf der Arbeit aufs Klo gehe.
Und das seit Jahren schon,
seit ich hier daheim
mein Klo mit Spülung habe.
also ich habe ja so ein Klo mit Popo-Spülung, wo du so einen Wasserstrahl in den Popo sauber machst.
Das ist einfach viel angenehmer und milder für den Hintern, als mit Klopapier dran herum reiben.
Danach einmal Klopapier drüber, immer noch.
Aber seitdem gehe ich eigentlich ungern kacken unterwegs, sondern immer daheim, sofern möglich.
Ich hab die komplette, kein Aufsatz, ich hab die komplette Toilette von denen.
Pass auf, jetzt geht er ins Bett und call.
Es gibt doch, Leute, es gibt doch sogar ein Video.
Hier, ich hab sogar ein Video über mein Klo gemacht, guck da.
da ist die Fernbedienung, wenn man da drauf drückt
und da ein Leak
und wenn man da drauf drückt, dann
kommt Wasser raus, guckt
falls man das sieht
Wasser
ja, ich habe sogar ein Update-Video
gemacht
8 Jahre Premium-Klo-Fazit
und die Fernbedienung
hat auch viel mehr Funktionen, also echt
echt nice
Oh ne
Guck mal, du kannst doch nicht mal ausschlafen
Du arbeitest bis um 12 Uhr nachts
Bis nachts im Bett am Liegen
Und denkst, fuck, jede Sekunde kann ein Anruf kommen
Und dann wirst du morgens um 8 Uhr angerufen
Wie, wie, wie, also ganz ehrlich
Surviving trifft's hier echt
Flashback
Ticket pending, beste
Es ist wirklich, ich kann es nur mal tun,
es ist wirklich Essen und Arbeiten.
Was anderes gibt es nicht mehr.
Und teilweise halt auch noch Essen während dem Arbeiten.
Aber
Arbeiten da nur Asiaten?
Wo soll das sein war Amazon.
Also das jetzt nicht.
Aber das.
Wie ist das in Deutschland? Wird dort extra Einsatz auf der Arbeit generell belohnt oder bestraft?
Was meinst du mit extra Einsatz?
Meinst du jetzt, wenn du länger arbeitest, als sein müsste?
Oder wenn du quasi dir besonders Mühe gibst?
Oder meinst du extra Einsatz, du hast Rufbereitschaft am Wochenende?
Also Rufbereitschaft am Wochenende, das wird generell bezahlt.
zumindest überall, wo ich es bisher machen musste, gemacht habe, wurde es extra bezahlt.
Sowohl die Rufbereitschaftszeit als auch dann den tatsächlichen Einsatz.
Der tatsächliche Einsatz wird meistens mit Arbeitszeitgutschrift bezahlt und die Rufbereitschaft mit Geld.
Länger arbeiten, mehr Prognose, die andere nicht lösen, einfach mehr Einsatzzeug.
Und ja, also je nach Unternehmen, mag auch welche geben, wo das nicht der Fall ist, aber in der Regel muss man anerkennen, Einsatz zahlt sich aus.
Egal, ob das jetzt bei deutschen Unternehmen ist oder nicht.
Allerdings, eine Sache musst du beachten und das ist überall so, Einsatz alleine reicht nicht.
Du musst das auch regelmäßig der Welt mitteilen, dass du das machst.
Also es hat jetzt keinen Sinn, wenn du dich voll reinhängst und super komplizierte Sachen löst, die außer dir keiner lösen könnte.
Und das machst du permanent, drei Jahre am Stück, aber keiner kriegt es mit.
Wenn du einen guten Chef hast, verkauft er das, ja, auch schon gut.
Du musst dich halt darauf verlassen, dass du einen guten Chef hast.
Aber du musst das in der Regel, egal ob du einen guten Chef hast oder nicht, du musst das, also mindestens deinem Chef musst du es regelmäßig erzählen.
auch nochmal drauf pochen,
hier, guck mal da und da und dem zeigen.
Wenn du einen guten Chef hast, freut er sich aus
und sagt, gut, wunderbar, habe ich wieder was Neues
zum Erzählen.
Aber es schadet nicht und man sollte
sich nicht nur darauf verlassen, dass der Chef ist,
alles immer gut in die Welt raus
posaunt. Es schadet nicht
und aus meiner Sicht ist es eigentlich fast schon
Pflicht, wenn man gute Sachen macht,
die muss man ab und zu ein bisschen
breittreten.
Ja, das ist natürlich auch Mist. Also man muss das, wenn man was Gutes macht, man muss das auch breit treten. Sagen wir es mal ganz übertrieben. Sagen wir mal, du machst immer 100% tolle Sachen. Dann ist das nice, vielleicht verkauft es dein Chef gut, aber wahrscheinlich wirst du karrieretechnisch besser fahren, du würdest weniger gute Sachen machen, weniger oft gute Sachen machen und die restliche Zeit nutzen,
über die Sachen, die du gemacht hast,
zu reden.
Da gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten,
also mindestens mal bei deinem Chef,
da gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
So gut wie alle Unternehmen haben
irgendwelche Informationsaustauschdinger,
wo man sich anmelden kann,
ich würde da gerne mal was zeigen
oder sowas in der Richtung.
Das mag cringe erscheinen,
ist aber am Ende nicht cringe.
Oder du musst darüber hinwegsehen,
dass du es vielleicht cringe findest.
es gibt jede Menge Informationsveranstaltungen bei fast allen Unternehmen,
wo man ab und zu mal auch was zeigen kann von dem, was man gemacht hat.
Und spätestens dann kriegen es halt auch die Leute mit und nicht nur dein Chef,
sondern auch vielleicht der Chef von deinem Chef.
Nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel, ja.
Nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel.
Wir hatten letztes Jahr, ich mach mal kurz ein bisschen Musik an.
Wir hatten letztes Jahr, Ende des Jahres irgendwann, ich weiß nicht, wann das war,
ist auch egal hatten wir eine abteilungsversammlung ja wobei da muss
ich sagen diese diese wo diese meetings wo war es wie macht das bleibt sehr
geschlossen innerhalb vom team also wenn man die möglichkeit hat das team
übergreifend zu präsentieren und ein bisschen breit zu treten würde ich das
machen ja es gibt manche manche chefs oder abteilungsleiter haben so eine
so eine, nennen wir es mal, Sprechstunde gab es in der alten Firma bei uns.
Da konntest du, einmal im Monat konntest du dich anmelden,
dass du eine Stunde mit dem Abteilungsleiter redest.
Da kann man so Sachen breitreden.
Ich hatte da nie Bock hinzugehen, ich war auch nur einmal da.
Aber jetzt mal ein Beispiel, was man tatsächlich...
Ja, glaub mir.
Meinst du, ich bin der krasse extrovertierte Typ?
Denkt ihr das allen Ernstes nach dem, was ich euch immer in meinen Streams erzähle?
Ich bin der Inbegriff von Kellerkind.
aber ich habe gelernt, dass es sich auszahlt und vor allem, dass es auch Spaß machen kann.
Mittlerweile mag ich das, eine Viertelstunde, 20 Minuten über Sachen zu erzählen, die mir gefallen
und ich weiß, den anderen bleibt jetzt nichts anderes übrig, als mir zuzuhören.
Ich habe aber auch einen gewissen Anspruch darauf, das relativ interessant zu machen.
Zum Beispiel, letztes Jahr hatten wir eine Abteilungsversammlung, das heißt quasi alle aus IT waren da
Und dafür kann man sich im Vorfeld anmelden, ob man dort was vorstellen will.
Zwischen 10 und 20 Minuten.
Ich habe gesagt, ich nehme so einen Slot.
So einen 20 Minuten Slot.
Und habe dann präsentiert was.
Und zwar, ich habe für einen unserer Services unser Monitoring verbessert.
Und zwar habe ich einen eigenen, das haben wir sogar im Stream teilweise hier gemacht.
Ich habe einen Prometheus-Exporter in Go programmiert, der in Kubernetes als Sidecar für diesen Pod mitläuft und Metriken zur Verfügung stellt über diesen Service, weil diesen Service, den kannst du sonst sehr schwer überwachen.
Der hat zwar eine API, die bietet nicht genügend Informationen oder nicht das, was man haben will.
Und ich frage das quasi von der, außerdem gibt es die API auch nur auf Local Host, also quasi innerhalb des Pots.
Mein Prometheus-Exporter fragt die Daten ab, bereitet das auf und stellt es als Prometheus-Metriken bereit,
dann gecrawled werden können und dann kann man sich ein schönes Dashboard bauen.
Das habe ich vorgestellt, 20 Minuten in der Abteilungsrunde und das fanden die alle ganz toll.
Zumindest das, was ich gehört habe.
Natürlich, sag mal so, wenn du einen fragst, wie war's oder wenn einer zu dir kommt, der wird nicht zu dir kommen, wenn es kacke war und wenn du fragst, wie war's, wird kaum einer sagen, Max, ich habe noch nie so eine Scheißpräsentation gehört. Das sagt vielleicht eine Kollegin, mit der ich mich so ganz gut verstehe, aber in der Regel sagt man ja, war nice, weil du nett sein willst.
Ja, aber kam auch ganz gut an. Ich habe danach sogar noch Mails bekommen von Leuten, die wissen wollten, wie ich mein Image so klein gekriegt habe, mein Container-Image so klein gekriegt habe. Und schon hast du mal 300 Leute erzählt, was du für geile Sachen machst. Das hilft deinem Chef auch, das besser zu verkaufen.
Stell dir mal vor, dein Chef kriegt das nächste Mal Budget oder will Budget beantragen, um auf die Leute gehaltsmäßig oder einmalzahlungsmäßig oder was auch immer zu verteilen und der muss jetzt seinem Chef erklären, warum er mehr Budget haben will für Einmalzahlung oder so.
Da fällt es dem doch viel einfacher, wenn er sagen kann, ey, guck mal hier, Pseudo-Pleas hat sich hier voll reingehängt mit seinem was auch immer und dein Chef weiß, ja Moment, das ist doch der von der letzten Abteilungsversammlung, der hat da was vorgestellt.
Ja, dann ist klar, dann machst du auch die Kohle viel leichter locker.
Also, es ist besser, nur die Hälfte geile Sachen zu machen und die andere Zeit damit zu verbringen, darüber zu reden, was man für geile Sachen gemacht hat.
So durft es sich erstmal anhört, aber das bringt einen weiter als 100% geile Sachen machen.
Unter anderem Multistage-Bild und Distroless-Images.
Ich finde es immer noch sehr verwirrend, dass es ein Distroless Debian gibt.
Weil entweder ist es Distroless oder es ist Debian.
Ich weiß, warum es so heißt. Die Benamung ist aber bescheuert.
Ich habe mir übrigens... Wisst ihr, ich habe mir ein gutes Thema für einen Stream überlegt.
Ne, ne, nicht Alpine. Nix, nix Alpine. Ich mag Alpine nicht.
Ich habe mir ein gutes Thema für einen Stream überlegt.
Und zwar, wir bauen ein Container-Image.
Wir fangen an mit einem Noob-Ansatz.
Und dann ist das Container-Image 2 GB groß.
und wir werden das dann durch verschiedene Techniken verschlanken,
bis das Image nur noch 20 MB groß ist.
Wir paketieren KekWiS Service mal wieder.
Ich habe so eine Anwendung, so eine Demo-Anwendung gebaut,
KekWiS Service, das ist im Prinzip nur ein Endpunkt,
der hier dieses Bild rotiert oder nicht als GIF.
Quaas, quasi Quaas.
Der ist immer gut als
Demo-Anwendung.
Marc Alpine auch nicht. Willkommen im Club.
Weiß ich noch nicht.
Was heißt Container-Image?
Weißt du, was mit Container gemeint ist?
Mit einem Linux-Container? Oder generell mit einem
korrekterweise, müsste man ja eigentlich mittlerweile
sagen, glaube ich, OCI-Container, oder?
Ist das korrekt?
Bei Container denkst du, ja, wir bauen ein Docker-Image, genau.
Früher hat man das Docker-Image genannt.
Heute nennt man das eigentlich Container-Image, weil die Container-Runtime nicht automatisch Docker sein muss.
Das kann Docker sein, das kann aber auch Kubernetes sein, das kann auch Nerd-CLI oder wie das heißt sein, Potman oder sonst was.
hilft da auch so was wie zum beispiel schulung zu geben für die teamkollegen mit dem man sich
mit dem man sich ja ja ja ja er nicht nur teamkollegen sondern es ist sinnvoll auch
wenn du ein thema hast bei dem du dich gut auskennt schulung anzubieten über team mit
übergreifend hinaus ja also bei größeren unternehmen ist ja oft so dass es so eine
sonne so eine learning plattform oder so gibt da kannst du dich auch eintragen lassen für ich
gebe geht schulung oder sowas zum beispiel oder was auch immer du da
schulst also wenn es ein gescheites unternehmen ist dann ermöglichen die
das auch weil es bringt ja allen was wenn du leute hast die sich mit einem
thema auskennen musste dir keine consultant leute holen
Also für mich klingt dieses, bei uns geht das nicht, weil Gehaltsstufen oder weil Gehaltsgefüge oder sowas, das klingt für mich immer nach einer easy Ausrede, die so ein Chef in seinem Chefhandbuch stehen hat oder ein Abteilungsleiter in seinem Handbuch stehen hat.
Was kann ich sagen, wenn mich einer nach mehr Geld fragt, womit er sich zufrieden gibt?
Zum Beispiel, ah, das passt nicht ins Gehaltgefüge, ah, das ist bei uns nicht möglich wegen Gehaltsstufen.
Für mich ist sowas immer erstmal ein bisschen, ah, ich hab so den Eindruck, der will nicht und hat keinen Bock sich mit auseinanderzusetzen.
Also es gibt ja mehrere Möglichkeiten, wie man ein Gehalt anpassen kann.
Das heißt ja nicht zwangsläufig, dass du monatlich jetzt mehr Geld bekommen musst immer. Es gibt auch die Möglichkeiten Einmalzahlungen, Prämien, erfolgsabhängige Ziele definieren, wie gut hast du was geschafft, dann zwischen 80 und 120% Einmalzahlung. Es gibt ja viele mehr Möglichkeiten Einfluss auf dein Jahresgehalt auszuüben, als die monatliche Zahlung muss mehr sein.
Und da hat eigentlich immer eine Führungskräfte einen gewissen Spielraum, was zu machen.
Und wenn die immer mit so pauschalen Sachen kommen, dann wollen sie nicht oder haben keinen Bock, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen.
Wenn es so starr ist, da gibt es nichts außer der Reihe, dann ist das aber auch komplett, wie soll man sagen, Einsatz...
Also, nee, ähm...
Komplett wieder, also das steht, wenn es keine Möglichkeit gibt,
für besonderen Einsatz oder besondere Leistung oder besonderes Engagement,
äh, auch, ähm, besonders belohnt zu werden,
dann muss man sich auch nicht wundern, wenn die Leute eben keinen besonderen Einsatz bringen.
Das ist eine ganz einfache Anreizthematik, ja?
Also, wenn es keine Anreize gibt, das zu machen, oder man sogar lernt,
man hat es gemacht, man hat Einsatz gebracht,
man hat extra Sachen gemacht, man hat coole Sachen gemacht
und man dann lernt, man hat da gar nichts davon
und die Leute, die einfach 24-7 ihr Leben chillen,
kriegen exakt das Gleiche
und man hat nichts daraus irgendwie Positives ziehen können,
außer mehr Arbeit gehabt.
Da wird man sich in Zukunft das zweimal überlegen,
ob man dann tatsächlich mehr Einsatz bringt.
Das klingt so ein bisschen nach Behörde.
Okay, wir müssen das Video fertig gucken, weil langsam kriege ich echt Hunger.
Pippo Fettheim.
Was soll er denn noch für Karriere-Goals haben?
Neben 24-7-Kreisel-Crime bleibt ja da keine Zeit mehr, so wie es aussieht.
Ja, müssen wir auch mal wieder machen.
Kann es sein,
dass es eine Plattform von ihm ist?
Weil diese krassen Karriere-Criner bei Amazon und Google, die machen ja nicht nur krassen Karriere-Crines, die machen in ihren 5 Minuten Freizeit ja meistens auch noch irgendwie 3 Startups auf.
Kostenlos Pizza, da wäre ich auch sofort am Start.
Es ist wirklich Arbeiten, Essen, Arbeiten, Essen, oder?
Okay, Afterwork müssen wir uns nicht angucken.
Und hier ist Sunday Snowboarding.
Wird er denn angerufen beim Snowboarden noch?
Uncooked.
Shit.
Ich bin gegrillt.
Also das ist schon brutal, oder?
Das machst du nicht ewig, nee, das ist Speedrun to Burnout.
Also das ist wirklich krass.
Also, der war ja im Prinzip 24-7 im Einsatz.
Nach der Woche brauchst du erstmal drei Monate Urlaub.
Länger als ein, zwei Jahre kannst du das auch nicht machen.
Ey, Hüde, das ist echt heftig.
Naja, das ist dann wirklich nur noch durchhalten, bis du gar nicht mehr kannst und dann hoffen, dass es ausreicht.
Updates habe ich heute schon gemacht, aber Arch Linux.
Was meins ist Local. Moonlight brauchen wir eh nicht mehr.
Wollen wir gleich mal aninstallen.
Bam, weg damit.
Oh, so.
Solche Gelder sind bei uns unvorstellbar.
Ja.
Also, K. mit Stocks.
Mit Stongs ist schon heftig.
Gut, man darf nicht vergessen,
die hasseln da auch deutlich mehr
als bei uns.
Und da ist auch vieles
deutlich teurer als bei uns, aber nichtsdestotrotz
bleibt unterm Strich trotzdem mehr übrig.
hast wieder eine katze habe ich nicht
die spitze des boomer humors an das halte ich jetzt heraus das halte ich an
ostern kommen schon wieder die ganzen die ganzen boomer mit ihren eierwitzen
auf facebook
das ist boomer es passt zu boomer bei uns reicht auch 100 kaum echt schädigt das stimmt aber man
darf nicht vergessen in deutschland verdient wirklich die allerwenigsten 100k plus im jahr
ich benutze kein facebook
Osterrufbereitschaft
haut richtig rein, ja
100k ist nicht so viel
sag das mal
unserem Durchschnittsgehaltsverdiener
in Deutschland
ja
gab es doch hier Spiegel
Durchschnitts
die hatten auch so ein ja kann man gucken dass mir gerade zu high iq
mit 3 mit 3000 mit 3000 gehörst du schon zu paare ohne kinder ja gesamt vollkommen
da gehörst schon so in den Top 17 Prozent.
Also Nettoeinkommen ist das jetzt.
Also das ist schon,
100k im Jahr ist für viele schon sehr viel.
Ich weiß, dass es sicherlich nicht genug ist,
um alles zu machen, was man machen will.
Aber vielleicht muss man auch sich mal irgendwann überlegen, ob das wirklich alles das ist, was man unbedingt braucht.
Also ich komme gut klar mit der Kohle, die ich bekomme.
Also ich weiß es hochgerechnet auf fünf Tage, weiß ich es nicht.
Aber ich kann euch sagen, ein Kollege von mir, der mit mir angefangen hat, den ich auch geworben habe, der hat ein minimal geringeres Base-Gehalt als ich, aber nicht der Rede wert.
Der hat letztes Jahr bei 5-Tage-Woche mit Rufbereitschaft um die 120 oder fast 125k brutto rausgehabt.
und da kannst du nix sagen das ist enorm viel geld für eigentlichen echt angenehm job wie
viele wochen rufbereitschaft ich bin mir nicht sicher wie viele wochen es im jahr sind bei uns
ist das eher so aufgeteilt dass das tageweise gemacht wird um das bisschen anstrengungs mäßig
zu optimieren und dass jeder gleich viel Wochenendschichten oder Wochenendrufbereitschaft
bekommt. Dass nicht einer gar nichts und einer total viel hat.
Führungsposition weder noch. Senior Linux Engineers sind wir beide.
Klingt cooler. Früher war das mal Serveradmin und zwischenzeitlich war das, weil man ganz cool ist,
DevOps engineer oder so war meine alten job war ich senior DevOps engineer bin ich senior linux engineer
Wie das heißt doch vollkommen wurscht
Wie alt ist dieser kollege 40 so alt wie ich
der finn bis seck winops ja seit reliability engineer das gibt die sind gerade bei uns auf
der arbeit dabei die job bezeichnung umzubenennen mal gucken wie ich in zwei wie mein job in zwei
jahren heißt es mir folgt ist mir auch vollkommen wurscht ehrlich gesagt hast du gewusst dass in
frankfurt voll viele millionäre gibt
also ich hätte es ich wusste es nicht aber ich hätte es mir denken können weil
es kaum einen platz auf der welt gibt wo krasse armut und kurz vorm abkratzen und
millionäre so dicht aneinander vorbei gehen wie im frankfurter bahnhofsviertel
da hast du den einen typ damit der spritze im arm wobei heute ist es eher
ja, Spritze ist nicht mehr so angesagt,
ja, ähm,
sagen wir mal, der eine, der mit der Spritze
in der Ecke auf der Straße
liegt, kurz vor dem Abkratzen ist, und der Typ,
der in seinem Porsche zwei Meter
vorbeifährt mit Millionen,
also, das ist wirklich, in Frankfurt
Bahnhofsviertel
ist krasser Reichtum und Armut
sehr nah beieinander.
Nein, wir vibecoden mich.
IT-Buzzword,
vibecoden.
Ja, und in Frankfurt ist jedes, das stimmt, jedes zweite Geschäft ist irgendein Juwelier oder Goldladen.
Gerade in der Copy-Paste-Ecke, die ich euch schon ein paar Mal auf Google Maps gezeigt habe.
Es gibt, wenn ihr am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof seid und, äh, was ist das?
Ist das Münchner Straße?
Ich glaube Münchner Straße ist das.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, welche Straße, welche, ne, vor der Kaiserstraße.
Ich glaube Münchner Straße.
Die ist Copy-Pasted.
Du hast immer Friseur, Imbiss, Schmuckladen, Hotel.
Und das ist drei Einfahrten lang exakt immer copy-pasted.
Friseur, die heißen dann ein bisschen anders.
Aber es ist immer Friseur, Imbiss, irgendein Hotel.
Sport fährt jetzt auch zwischendurch.
Nein, schon lange nicht mehr.
Ist das ein Zufall, dass das Rotlichtfett direkt neben dem Banksektor ist?
historisch weiß ich nicht aber muss immer muss sagen ist frankfurt rotlichtviertel ist ergibt
es ja kaum noch ist also ist ja ist ja kaum noch was da im vergleich zu früher es gibt also die
ganze kaiserstraße war ja wohl früher so wenn man das historisch anguckt rotlichtviertel kaiserstraße
ist nichts mehr rotlichtviertel das einzige was jetzt noch übrig ist es glaube ich taunusstraße
hinten ein bisschen
rot ist. Da hast du ja im Prinzip
irgendwie
ein paar Shops,
wo du dir Sachen kaufen kannst
und irgendwie drei, vier puffst. Das war's.
Also das ist übrig geblieben von Frankfurt der Rotlicht.
Es gibt kaum noch was. Das wurde
alles verdrängt von irgendwelchen Friseuren,
Supermärkten, Schmuck an und Verkauf.
Oder
Döner,
Bratwurst,
was auch immer. Essen.
Es gibt kaum noch was.
Und ich gehe, also wenn das so weiter geht,
Shisha-Bars hast du da auch, ja.
Aber nicht so viele wie Friseure oder Barbershops.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es in ein paar Jahren
wahrscheinlich gar nichts mehr großartig gibt in Frankfurt,
in der, so wie früher.
Woher weißt du das so genau?
Weil ich da regelmäßig durchlaufe.
KI-Weifels werden das obsolet machen.
Da muss KI noch ein bisschen zulegen.
In Frankfurt, in der Innenstadt, wahrscheinlich ist es...
Ja, ja, ja.
Gehe ich mal von aus, dass das profitabler ist.
Es gibt deutlich mehr Friseure und Barbershops als Rotlichtsachen dort.
Und außerdem, paar Straßen weiter, wisst ihr ja,
Frankfurt, Goethe-Straße, Louis Vuitton-Store
Zahl die Kollektion bar, fick auf Sponsor
Ist auch in der Ecke da hinten
Goethe-Straße
Naja, genug geschwätzt, Leute
Ich hab übertrieben Hunger
Ich geh jetzt was essen
3 Stunden 35
War ganz schön lange am Start heute
Erstmal muss ich was trinken
Hals schon ganz trocken
Okay Leute, wir sehen uns
Bis zum nächsten, Stream macht's gut, CU